>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> David Mao: Good morning everyone.
My name is David Mao and I have
the privilege and honor of serving
as the Acting Librarian of Congress.
So first off, welcome to
the Library of Congress,
the world's largest library
and our nation's first
federal cultural institution.
Here at the Library of Congress,
we recognize the importance
of all types of diversity and how
diverse cultures enrich our nation.
So I'm very honored this morning
to open this special program
which also celebrates the 200th
anniversary of the arrival
of Laurent Clerc and Thomas Hopkins
Gallaudet to America in August 1816.
I understand that nine months after
their arrival, the first school
for the deaf was founded
in Hartford, Connecticut
and then 48 years after that,
Gallaudet University here
in our own Washington, DC.
It became the first school
for the advanced education
of the deaf and hard of hearing.
So today's program is cosponsored
by the Library of Congress Center
for the Book and the
National Literacy--
I'm sorry, National
Literary Society of the Deaf.
And it's all about opening the lines
of communication among
the various deaf cultures
and the libraries that serve them.
The primary focus of course is to
build support for libraries to work
with organizations serving the deaf.
Now, since 1993, the Library of
Congress Deaf Association has served
as a resource to, not
only the library
but also the labor
organizations here to identify
and eliminate discrimination--
discriminatory policies
that affect deaf and hard
of hearing employees here at
the Library of Congress and also
to encourage the employment of
employees here at the library.
The Library's Interpreting
Services Program, benefited here
of course today by great
people, is part of the Office
of Equal Employment Opportunity
and Diversity Programs
and it is currently
hosting a series of programs
that explores deaf culture
here in the United States.
So I want to thank the National
Literary Society of the Deaf
and its president, Alec McFarlane,
for bringing this important
program to the library.
The Library Center for the Book
whose mission is to promote books,
reading, libraries and
literacy has for many,
many years recognized the
society as a long-time reading
and literacy promotion partner.
And we're very, very happy about the
collaboration between the library
and the society and the
promotion on all the good work
that the partnership does together.
So now I'm going to turn the
program over to the director
of the Library Center for
the Book, Dr. John Cole.
Thank you very much
and enjoy the program.
>> John Cole: Thank you, David.
I'm John Cole.
I am the director of the Center for
the Book in the Library of Congress.
Its job is to help stimulate public
interest in books, in reading,
in literary work, and in literacy.
So I have a wonderful
job in the center
that was created many years
ago by Librarian of Congress,
Daniel Boorstin who many
of you may know about.
He wanted the Library of Congress
to reach out to all audiences,
to express the importance of books
and literary work and of literacy.
We have a partnership
program and you are part
of the partnership program.
The National Literary Society
for the Deaf has been a partner
for about 10 years, and this
is our second major program.
So, I am very happy
that you can be here
and that we can have a
wonderful day together here
at the Library of Congress.
You see around you some displays.
We're going to have--
we have posters.
We are going to have
interesting talks.
And from authors, from librarians,
we will be able to at the end
of the day think about deaf
culture and all cultures together.
So it's a wonderful highlight
day for all of us here.
I will be serving to introduce the
speakers and if you have questions
about the Library of Congress today,
please ask me or ask my associate
and Bonnie who is in the back row
who also be-- will
be with us all day.
So thank you and we're
beginning to start our day
with another important person
who's helped plan this for us
and he has his own special
statement in for you before we move
in to the program itself.
We are very grateful to Alec
McFarlane who is the President
of the National Literary Society
of the Deaf, not only for his work
in this society and being a
partner for the Center for the Book
but especially for his
help in organizing today
and in responding to you so well.
We have a wonderful group of
people and I look forward to being
with you today and would like to
call on Alec to say a few words.
Alec?
>> Alec McFarlane: Thank you, John.
>> John Cole: Thank you, Alec.
>> Alec McFarlane: Thank you.
Hello, everyone here.
My name is Alec McFarlane.
I'm the President of the National
Literary Society of the Deaf.
I am very happy that John Cole and
Mr. Mao gave us the stage here today
to share our stories about culture,
different things in the deaf world.
And I can't tell you how
our authors are going to say
and I can't tell you what
workshops we're going to do
but I can tell you,
there are back stories.
You know, "Oh, it's everything,
culture has back stories."
And that back story
is that [inaudible].
We have pay.
Give us foundations for our
language that was brought to America
and America is using them
now as a cultural bridge.
And we're bringing language.
You can go anywhere in the
world and same sign language.
But the culture and it's
not something that's
to sign language, it's not.
You know, the people
are all varies of life.
I mean, we have all the
different kinds of people
who are deaf by any definition.
We define deaf person as someone
with various hearing
levels and has [inaudible].
And here with our culture,
we're trying to break a bridge
those barriers to people.
And so our authors today will tell
you stories about the world, kids,
and adults, and civil war.
I mean, we have a lot of things that
are cultural and it's not limited
to the people because we have
the people in every race,
every religion, every corner of
earth who will find that people.
So here today, what bring people who
can help us bridge that differences,
who would bring people
to deaf community to go
to the outside community.
And we have people doing that now.
And I think I'm now going
to introduce our friend here
from Gallaudet University,
Dr. Genie Gertz.
Please.
[ Applause ]
>> Genie Gertz: Good morning.
I'm really proud to be here.
I'm representing Gallaudet
University.
I am the dean of the
College of Arts and Sciences.
We call that CAS but
I am not alone in my--
So, we are not alone
in our acronyms.
We call the Library
of Congress the LOC,
and we have many, many
acronyms here.
That being said, the College of Arts
and Sciences, CAS, we look at that
as an exclusive representation of
a variety of fields, from arts,
to humanities, to sciences and more.
And that is where the
important collaborations happen
where we can collaborate
with the Library of Congress.
The picture that you see there, the
domes of the Library of Congress,
I can actually see that
everyday from my office window.
So as I look out into the
landscape, I can see that dome
and I see it right next
to the White House.
It's a nice reminder of how
those collaborations happen
and how you can use those to
develop a bank of knowledge
so that everyone can
benefit from that.
And I'm very thrilled to see that
the Library of Congress for many,
many years has not
battled, but supported us
and we have collaborate
together because the body
of knowledge feeds us to further
fuel research and continue a field.
And without the bases, we
wouldn't have that research.
And Gallaudet University
represents a home for many,
many people who have
come to our university.
They study.
They make it through their
years at Gallaudet in a variety
of different disciplines.
The students who were in those
different disciplines also complete
internships and then they
go out into the world
and are able to affect influence.
But all of that support comes from
places like the Library of Congress.
You are our foundation for
that body of knowledge.
As you know, Gallaudet
University has a specific mission.
And we all work to support
the students to be able
to go out into the world.
At the same time, we do
support our bilingual mission
and it is an opportunity for
students to come and study
at Gallaudet to really delve
into those different aspects
of like he was mentioning
culture and the body of knowledge,
the community, the
culture and the world.
Through that progress, you
can see students really grow
and develop as individuals.
And you see them expand
their body of knowledge.
It becomes global knowledge
so that they're ready to go
out into the world and
have an influence on it.
We have many, many
different departments.
And within those, a variety of
skills, we have the Department
of ASL and Deaf Studies that
feeds into expanding the body
of knowledge related to
ASL and deaf culture.
I had the biggest honor and
privilege of being a coeditor
of the Deaf Studies Encyclopedia.
It was just released early
this year in the month--
we're in the month of April now.
And so, just at the very beginning
of 2016, that book was released.
The Encyclopedia of Deaf studies is
inclusive of a variety of things,
different disciplines
within deafness.
So again, I talk about
art, linguistics, history.
All of these different
disciplines are contained
within the encyclopedia.
And it is my hope that
one day, it will make it
into the Library of
Congress archives.
At the same time, we
developed this with a purpose.
We want to collect the different
contributions that have happened
over the last 300 centuries.
We have over 300 entries
and different authors
who have been included in this
encyclopedia, some of our authors
who will be actually
presenting later today,
Dr. Henry Lang for instance.
The purposes of this is to share
and disseminate that knowledge.
Again, it all circles back
to the purpose of this event,
to bring us together, to
collaborate, to support one another
and expand that body of knowledge.
I do want to recognize
two of our interns here.
They're interns at the Library
of Congress this semester.
I don't know if they're
in the audience.
But I knew that-- I know
that they plan to come today.
It is a clear example
of that partnership
between Gallaudet University
and the Library of Congress.
And what they learn here,
they're going to be able to carry
with them into their careers.
The two interns that I would
like to specifically recognize are
James Newton and Jessica Rimando.
If you see them later today,
please congratulate them for all
of the work that they've
done and encourage them
to continue that body of knowledge.
I want to thank all of
you for your support.
Now, Gallaudet thanks
you, I thank you.
And before I close, I'm not
sure if you all know or not,
but Gallaudet University was
founded by Thomas Hopkins Gallaudet
for his history with
deafness as I just explained.
The Library of Congress
was established
and then ultimately Gallaudet.
There is a connection to
the Library of Congress
and Gallaudet University.
In the Jefferson Building,
this is the Madison Building,
but if you go over to the Jefferson
Building, they have a mural
or a mosaic that's on the wall.
And there are a variety
of different people
who were important
throughout history.
Thomas Hopkins Gallaudet
is in that mosaic.
So, we do have a strong connection
with the Library of Congress,
and that is further proof of it.
We are embedded into the Library
of Congress and we look forward
to continuing that
partnership in the future.
So, thank you so much and I hope
you enjoy the rest of your day.
Thank you.
>> John Cole: Well, thank you
so much for getting us started
and presenting the
Gallaudet connection--
the physical connection, which
is in one of the galleries
in the Jefferson Building.
And if you haven't seen it,
someday I hope you will.
I will later in the day actually
show you a guidebook to the Library
of Congress Building
that shows you the hall
for that Gallaudet
recognition is there.
I forgot to mention earlier
two things that are important.
One is that we are
filming this presentation
to show today's work
including the presentations
on the Library of Congress website.
So, it will be available in a month
or two and I will let people know
of when they can see the program
and also share the presentations
so people who are not here will
be able to hear the presentations
and get a sense of the
partnerships that we are encouraging
through today's cross
sections and conversations.
Second part is that the National
Literary Society for the Deaf is one
of 80 organizations that
already are part of the Center
for the Book's literacy and
reading promotion group.
And we meet once a year, the
whole group, to exchange ideas
and to specialize with some little--
some special presentations that
relate to some of our partners
that others may not know about.
And so, next year, we will be able
to talk a little bit about today
and build bridges-- continue
to build bridges I think
with other partners
who share interests
in not only American culture,
but specifically in reading,
in education and promotion.
So, you already are part
of this through our website
and through our promotions
in our annual meetings.
We will continue the
work that we're--
have started and that we are
presenting especially today.
I mentioned that the Center
for the Book specializes
in authors and writing.
And today is no exception.
And we have two outstanding
authors to hear from.
You'll have an opportunity to talk
with them and to buy their books.
And then in the afternoon program,
we have some special presentations
that makes the history of our
endeavors, the history of Gallaudet,
the history of a little bit
of the Library of Congress
and the use of our collections.
So, it's going to be a very
full and wonderful day.
The first president, I believe
Ricardo was the first president.
But Ricardo Lopez is here to
get us started before we hear
from our authors with
some information
about the history of
the literary society.
And I believe he also has
a PowerPoint presentations,
so it's my pleasure now to
welcome to the stage Ricardo Lopez.
Ricardo? Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ricardo Lopez: Thank
you, Mr. Cole.
It's such a pleasure
to be here once again.
I used to be the president
of NSLD-- NLSD.
I joined the society when
I was still a student
at the University of Maryland.
And Alice Hagemeyer
invited me to attend some
of the society's meetings.
And I learned more and
more about the group
through attending those meetings and
realized I had found a home there.
I became more and more
involved and decided
that not only would I be a
member, I would become president.
I had had some experience
with libraries prior to that
but it wasn't until I joined
the society that I learned
about the rich history in
the deaf community related
to libraries and literacy.
This organization was
founded in 1907.
So, as I said, it's very
long and rich history.
I remember 10 years ago when
we partnered with the center
for the book, and that we
continue these partnerships
that we've developed today.
Our goal is to continue
collaborating with others
to promote literacy
in the deaf community.
We hope that more deaf people
will be inspired to become authors
and that they will
help spread the word
of our deaf culture
and deaf history.
I majored in history and so that
is the theme of my presentation.
I'd like to talk to you a bit
today about the founders of NLSD.
I keep saying NSLD.
NLSD. If you'd like
to read the slide,
NLSD is one of the oldest
organizations of the deaf in the US.
And the mission is to
promote deaf culture,
especially in public libraries.
And so this partnership that
we have with the Library
of Congress is critical
to that mission.
When I left the position and Alec
McFarlane took over as president,
he continued that mission.
And it's work that we
are still having today.
As I said, the society
was founded in 1907.
And what happened was people
who were attending the Kendall
School got together and realized
that they enjoyed reading as a
way of expressing themselves,
talking about what
they were reading.
It was really more like a
book club in its early days.
The original meeting location
was Trinity Episcopal Church.
And I'd like now to show you the
image that I found of that church.
So here's an image of the church.
You've got the Capitol
Building right behind it.
This photo is from 1964-- 1864.
And this is where the founders
of our society today
began their meetings.
They met on a monthly
basis in this location.
Now this picture I found here
at the Library of Congress.
And this shows the exact
location on the map.
I was wondering if the
church was still standing
and I could actually see it
for myself, but what I found is
that it's no longer there.
Instead we have this building.
This building stands on the
location of the original church
and I believe it's now housing
the Department of Labor.
So if you happen to be
in that neighborhood,
you might see this building and
imagine the church that used
to stand there and be inspired
by our society's founders' work.
Here is a list of the
founders of the society.
Herbert, Gilbert, Arthur,
John, Albert and Roy.
I'd like to tell you a little
bit more about each of them.
Albert was a deaf person
who attended public schools
and he was a cataloguer in
the National Museum Library.
Arthur was an instructor of
art at the Kendall School
which was Gallaudet College,
now Gallaudet University.
Gilbert was the first
secretary of NLSD.
He worked as a photo engraver.
John Hotchkiss was faculty at
Gallaudet College for 53 years.
Herbert worked for
the US Weather Bureau.
And Roy Stewart worked
at the US Census Bureau.
Now, Francis Higgins
is pretty well known.
He was very active.
And my understanding is that
he became the first president
when NLSD was officially
established as an organization.
He was very involved in those
early days encouraging deaf people
to attend the meetings, to express
themselves in different ways,
all with a literary focus, whether
that's poetry, arts, writing.
He was a professor of chemistry.
I wonder if anyone in the audience
happens to remember Francis Higgins.
Are there a few of you who knew him?
Was he a good professor
during his time at Gallaudet?
>> Yes.
>> Ricardo Lopez: Now this
is Jeannette Mortzfeldt.
And I was lucky enough to get
to meet here while she was
still president of our society.
I think that I could say that I
still carry her message in my heart
of encouraging deaf people to
get involved in literary studies.
She passed away rather
recently, just in 2005.
In terms of our activities with NLSD
today, you see them listed here,
we do storytelling, we have artists
with us, we've formed various clubs,
we emphasize history, we have a
variety of occupations involved.
And partnering with the Center
for the Book has really helped us
continue the legacy of the society,
spreading the word to different
organizations, to public libraries,
collaborating with those entities.
Events like today.
I hope that you'll take information
and share that with your communities
and consider ways that you can
encourage your public library
to partner with NLSD.
So here is where I gathered my
information and I especially want
to recognize Agnes Sutcliffe
who's here in the audience.
She helped collect some of this
information for my presentation.
So thank you, Agnes, for your work.
[ Applause ]
And thank you all for
your attention.
>> John Cole: Well,
thank you very much.
Ricardo, are you-- Here we go.
We are now going to move.
I must say that I have learned
from Ricardo and our partnership
with this organization and
I am going to bring out on--
put on one of our tables some
activity brochures and more news
about what the Center for
the Book has been doing.
And we again have author talks, we
have presentations, we have projects
that we've developed
and one of the things
in the future we might consider
would be to do some kind
of a special project together
as we continue our partnership.
We're now going to hear from
Myron Uhlberg, who is an author,
who has been published
by Peachtree Press.
He is well known I think
to many of you as an author
of several different books,
and he is going to talk today
about a new book that he has
forthcoming, but he also,
I understand, is going to talk
a little bit about his career
as an author of books for
the author for the deaf,
talking about deaf
culture and working
on bringing our two
cultures together.
He also-- You also will
have a chance to beat him
and he will be signing books
at the Peachtree Press booth,
and we're very grateful
to Peachtree Press
for helping support him here today.
It's my pleasure to
introduce Myron Uhlberg.
Myron. Nice to meet you.
Very nice.
>> Myron Uhlberg: Hello,
my name is Myron Uhlberg.
I am hearing but my
parents were deaf.
I was the firstborn
of two deaf parents
and I learned sign
language from them.
However, I sign very
slowly and not very well.
I sign like an old person.
I do more conversational signing,
so I'm going to ask the
sign language interpreters,
the one to my left, to
interpret my presentation.
Thank you.
As has been said, you
live your life forwards
but you understand it backwards.
And so it is for me.
All my life, I have tried
to understand the child-parent
dynamic of my life.
My parents were deaf.
I was their firstborn child.
I could hear, and that has
made all the difference.
It was 1933, the absolute bottom of
the great depression and the height
of the bad old days when the deaf in
America were treated by the hearing
as somehow deficient, illiterate,
largely incapable of
self-sufficiency.
And as I witness everyday
of my childhood,
objects of scorn and often pity.
In my childhood some 80 years
ago, the hearing never tried
to understand or recognize or accept
my deaf mother and father as equals,
capable as were they of
raising two children.
And they often in my presence
expressed their incredulity
by their distaste of the beautiful
expressive gestural language
of the deaf, my first
language, as mere monkey talk.
We had no telephone, no
car, there was no TV,
let alone all the electronic
communicative devices
that exist today.
Thus, we were isolated.
In plain sight but ignored.
Within the larger hearing culture
of the apartment house we lived in
and the block we lived on and
the neighborhood we lived within.
The closest deaf family
live five miles away.
I felt as a child as an
immigrant minefield with one foot
in the old country of their birth
and the other foot in the country
and society and culture of the new
country that they had immigrated to.
Never for a minute did I feel
as a child that I had succeeded
in integrating the two vastly
different worlds I lived in,
the one of silence, thoughtfulness
and touch that expressed love.
And the other of incredible noise
and hustle and bustle with no time
for physical displays of emotion.
The one of speaking with
hands and face and body,
a language that demands
total attention.
A beautiful visual
language perceived
and appreciated through my eyes.
The other, spoken casually as if
I had overheard a conversation,
with little or no thought
or expression or emotion,
merely a tool for communication.
And so I live and grew
and accommodated myself
to both worlds everyday of my life.
Often confused, occasionally
maladjusted, frustrated,
aching to explain to others,
as well as to myself the
predicament I was in.
Until one day I left
my deaf home forever.
And all my questions unresolved
during my childhood were buried
in the daily short term quest
to fit in, to find a career,
a way of making my living,
finding a mate, starting a family.
I did all that with varying degrees
of success and failure and one day,
rather late in life, all
the questions returned.
Now demanding to be addressed
and answered if possible.
And so I began to write.
I had a story to tell.
A story I had lived, the story
of a unique culture that exist
in America largely ignored, isolated
by the larger culture
within which it exist.
The first book I wrote was
"Flying Over Brooklyn".
I was new to this game of
literature and storytelling.
So, somewhat unsure of myself,
I approached my story
side ways and not head on.
I would tell the tale
through metaphors,
images, allegories and symbols.
For example, never is it stated in
the story that the mother is deaf.
Snow would equal silence
and silence deafness.
The stillness of the vast snowfall
would muffle the boy's words
to all harsh meaningless
distracting noise.
The remaining senses
would be magnified.
The story is told through
the hearing boy's eyes.
Eyes that see everything acutely.
Nothing escapes his sight and
everything he sees has meaning.
I quote from the book.
I could see the parachute jump
and the giant wonder wheel.
Their sharp outlines now
softened by pillows of snow.
He smells the smell of roasted
peanuts and fat hotdogs.
He taste the sticky sweetness of
cotton candy melting in his mouth.
And he touches, he feels the
snowflakes melting on his cheeks
and the wind on his face.
The boy can fly.
He flies over everything.
He's above it all,
forever an observer.
Aware of, but not really a
part of his everyday world.
And in the end, his mother
awakens him from his dream.
And in the last illustration
views the deep vast snow.
The essence of deafness with her arm
around the boy's shoulders,
they are connected.
They are co-joined, the deaf
mother and her hearing child
through the love they
have for each other.
A love that overrides while
combining all the senses.
With my current book, my latest book
published by Peachtree Publishers,
titled "The Sound of All Things",
I begin the quarter of books,
which subject is the
perceptions of a hearing boy
and his beloved deaf mother and
father who live in a world of sound.
The dynamic of the hearing
child and his deaf parents
in a time now long
gone when the hearing
and deaf worlds were too
parallel but separate worlds.
In "The Sound of All Things",
the boy is six years old.
As long as he can remember,
the central fact of his life is
that his mother and father
cannot hear him nor can they hear
anything else.
They are deaf.
His deaf father tries to compensate
by using his remaining
senses to perceive sound.
At Coney Island, during a
fireworks display, while--
and I quote from the book.
The air was full of buzzing,
whistling, popping and screeching.
The lights and colors danced
across my father's face.
He held out his hands sniffing the
air as if to see and taste and touch
and smell the sounds of the
fireworks he couldn't hear.
This was normal for the boy,
and up until the age of six,
he gave the fact no special meaning.
But at the age of six,
his deaf father tasks him
to be his interface
with the hearing world.
He wants his son to be his ears.
"What do you hear,"
my father asked me.
"What does the ocean sound like?"
A big job for a small boy.
Overnight the roles reversed.
Now, in a way, while they
are out in the hearing world,
the boy is father to the man.
This was common back then
before TV and closed captioning,
movies with subtitle, emails,
instant messaging, short messaging,
TTY, computers, Google, iPhones,
texting, tweeting, fax machines,
and the portability of
iPads, FaceTime and Skype.
None of that existed then.
This book just published, "The Sound
of All Things", begins my story.
It is the foundation of every
book of mine that follows.
In the next book, "The Printer",
the boy is now 10 years old.
His father makes paper hats for
him when he comes home from work.
The boy is proud of his father.
His father has a job, a good job.
And he goes to work in a suit, a
shirt and a tie, and he wears a hat.
But why do the neighbors
feel sorry for him?
His father works for the New York
Daily News, the largest newspaper
in the world at the
time of the story.
They print two and a half
million copies a day,
five million on Sunday.
He's a printer, a compositor,
a good job.
He's proud to have that
he works with language.
He creates language with his hands.
He's a typesetter, a skill
he learned at Fanwood,
his deaf residential school.
The backstory is that the father
tells the boy how he first was taken
to school by his father
and left there.
The first day, he felt
abandoned and he cried.
But he soon realized that rather
than being lost, he had been found.
He now lived in a familiar world,
populated by boys who were just
like him, no longer that he
feel different and alone.
At night in the communal
bathroom, he learned the language
from the older boys, the
beautiful language of the deaf,
a gesture language of signs,
utilizing hands, face and body.
During the day, he learned to trade.
Most of the deaf boys learned
shoe repair or house painting.
He learned typesetting.
As a boy, I write, my father
learned how to speak with his hands.
As a man, he learned how to turn--
type letters into words
and sentences.
My father loved being a printer.
One day, the deaf father
takes his son on the subway
to the place where he works.
And now, the boy learns of the
reality of the workplace prejudice
that his father endures
every single day.
Quoting the book, sometimes
my father felt sad
about the way he was treated by
his fellow workers who could hear.
Because they could talk
to him with their hands,
they seemed to ignore him-- I mean,
because they couldn't talk to him,
they seemed to ignore him.
Years went by as my father and
the hearing worked side by side,
they never exchanged
a single thought.
On the subway ride back home,
he sees a deaf man selling
deaf alphabet cards.
His father is angry.
He yells in sign languages
into the deaf man.
The deaf man runs away,
and the entire subways
caused steer-- stares at us.
Be self-sufficient, the
father tells the boy.
Being deaf does not rob
a man of his dignity.
Being deaf does not define a person,
who they are or what they do,
how they live is what's important,
the father tells the boy.
The boy hardly understands what
the father is saying to him.
The signs pour from his father's
hands in a time of motion
and meaning, too hard to follow.
But the boy instinctively feels
his father's strength, his manhood,
his pride and above all,
his love for his son.
My next book, "Dad, Jackie
and Me", which has won many--
I'm happy to say, many, many
awards, the boy is now 13 years old.
For his birthday, his father
buys a pair of tickets
to the Brooklyn Dodger
baseball game at Ebbets Field
to see the first black
baseball player
in Major League Baseball,
Jackie Robinson.
The father identifies with
Robinson, a black man,
but the boy has no idea why.
The father never played
sports at his deaf school.
The emphasis was on learning
how to make a living,
and not how to play games.
At Ebbets Field, the boy
experiences prejudice
and discrimination
on a larger scale.
It seems to him that the entire
baseball world hates Jackie
Robinson, but they
don't even know him.
And the boy realized, it doesn't
matter, Robinson is black,
and having black skin is reason
enough for some people to hate him,
just like it seems to the boy
that some people hate his father
mostly because he cannot hear.
Now, he understands why his father
identifies with Jackie Robinson.
And the boy notes how some
people stare at his father
as he cheers Jackie
on in his deaf voice,
many with distaste on their face.
By the way, please note, the
new Ken Burns documentary film
about Jackie Robinson in
which I get to tell my story
about my deaf father and Jackie
Robinson and the book I wrote
about the two of them will premiere
this coming Monday on April 11th
on Public Broadcasting Channel.
The date and the time will be
announced in your local newspaper.
It's worth watching,
it's a tremendous movie
about Jackie Robinson.
As I say, I get to act out a little
bit of it in telling the story
which I love, which is my story.
The next book in this
story, "Hands of My Father",
which I don't have a copy with me.
I am absolutely proud to
advise you that this book,
"Hands of My Father", was chosen
by the Library of Congress
to be recorded as an
audible book for the blind.
They don't do that with
every book, but they did it
with my memoir, "Hands
of My Father".
This is a book, a memoir,
for all ages, any age.
It attempts through the eyes and
sensibility of one hearing child
to tell the story of his
deaf parents who were born
at the turn of the last century.
The firstborn in each
of their families
to hearing immigrant parents
who barely knew the
English language themselves
and never learned a
single word of sign.
They met in a place called Brooklyn,
a place that no longer exists.
It was then more rural, a series
of villages than an actual city,
in old Coney Island, the poor man's
Miami Beach, and they fell in love.
They found in each other their
mirror image, partners for life,
defenders of each other,
taking refuge in each other
in an often hostile hearing world.
They were now complete.
And then, against their
parents' well-intended
but heartless admonition that
they were children themselves,
they ignored their parents and they
dared to have a child who they loved
as they loved each other,
but who because he could hear
and they could not never
could be fully a part of them.
And now, they found
themselves in a unique world,
sandwiched between their hearing
parents and their hearing child.
The bridge in both directions
was for these two special people,
their infinite capacity for love.
But as is the case with race today,
much has changed for the deaf.
And yet, much remains the same.
You're all aware of the
changes primarily ADA,
Americans with Disability
Act, the amazing array
of electronic communicative
devices and platforms.
But in human terms, in human
interaction with the hearing world,
I've seen this, we all
have, much remains the same.
I learned just how little has
changed when I brought my mother
to live with me when she
turned 89 and broke her pelvis
and then had a series of strokes.
Soon upon arriving in my home,
she fell and broke her hip.
In time, her pelvis healed and
she survived a hip replacement.
But now, she was confined
to a wheelchair.
For the next six years, I witnessed
a series of events that hearken back
to the '30s and '40s, a time
of no sympathy for the deaf
or accommodation for the
deaf, to mention a few,
hospitals, doctors, nurses.
In the emergency room which you
all too often found yourself,
there was a sign regarding the
availability of an interpreter,
but there was no interpreter.
And when I pointed that out to
the staff, they looked at me.
I pointed out the sign that
was sitting in plain sight
at the admission desk,
they never noticed it,
they never didn't know
what an interpreter was.
They weren't aware of the
sign and what it called for.
Her doctors not aware of--
by law that now, he had
to have an interpreter,
were rendered virtually useless
in diagnosing and communicating.
They simply had no
time for a deaf person.
Her nurses, that was
the best of all.
Upon admission, I advised the
nurse's station, my mother is deaf.
Next morning above her bed
was a large handwritten sign,
patient is hard of hearing.
I pointed out that hard
of hearing was not deaf
and explained the difference.
OK. Early the next morning,
I found a new sign in place
above her bed, patient is deaf.
I swear this is true,
patient is deaf, shout.
Shout. And sure enough, while
I was in my mom's bedside,
a nurse came in, saw the
sign and began to shout
at my mother right in her face.
On another-- This is not
1930, this is eight years ago.
On another occasion, another
hospital visit, I came to a room
at dawn and she was sleeping,
and her hands were tied
to the bed railing
with strips of cloth.
I raged at the nurses, raged,
telling them that my
mother was deaf.
And the deaf communicate with
their hands using sign language.
One nurse was surprised,
your mother can talk?
She asked.
She didn't know that the
deaf had a language at all.
Her hospital said no text,
telephone in the emergency room,
the main library, anywhere--
or anywhere else I could find.
What's the conclusion?
Without me to interpret for
her in a medical setting,
she would have been
virtually helpless.
And for the general population,
the usual, stares, gaping mouths,
reaction ranging from
pointedly ignoring my mother
to overtly dismissing her.
But there were some examples
of how nothing has changed
that I experienced
that I have of my own.
I'm not deaf.
But ironically, I am now diagnosed
as being functionally deaf.
As a child while growing
up, I would often wonder,
what's it like to be deaf?
I would close my eyes
and imagine being blind,
but I couldn't close my
ears and imagine being deaf
like my mother and father.
Now, I don't have to
try to close my years,
time and age has taken care of that.
Without my hearing aids, the
most powerful in the market,
I would hear very little and
we can comprehend even less.
But even with the aids, I have
trouble understanding speech,
often getting things
wrong, sometimes comically.
But strangers don't find
it funny when I asked them
to please repeat themselves.
Their reactions range from
impatience to outright hostility.
What's the matter, you
stupid or something?
With all of this firsthand
experience between the deaf
and the hearing, with those
of my parents from the 1930s
on through the new millennium,
I'm convinced that the essential
problem is ignorance on the part
of the majority of hearing people.
And the heart of all
misunderstanding
between human beings
is that ignorance.
The more light we can shed on
this subject, deaf history,
current deaf life in America,
deaf culture and ASL through books
in libraries available to all,
the better we can tell
and preserve our story.
I've tried in some small
way with my books to provide
for the hearing a window
into the deaf world.
And in that regard, I
could come for the reading
of many similar reviewers'
comments and I'm quoting,
"This is a touching story
from an unusual perspective.
I learned so much about
the deaf and the ways
that society has mistreated them."
But the one review of many,
when I read it brought
tears to my eyes was this.
I quote, "I cannot help but think
while reading "Hands of My Father"
that even so many years
after his father's death,
Uhlberg is still acting as Lou's
translator, still bridging the gap
between his parents
and the hearing world.
He has become his father's hands."
With such encouragement, I
continue to write helping to learn
from writing while dredging up old
memories, long-buried and unexamined
but still burning brightly in mind
as they happened just yesterday,
new insights on those
two remarkable people,
Lou and Sally, my deaf parents.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Well,
thank you, Myron,
for really a wonderful personal
story based not only on your family,
but on your own experience.
And there's nothing that brings the
problems of being deaf to others
than the personal kinds
of anecdotes.
And the fact that you have told
these experiences in your books,
well, something is telling the
story and helping in many ways.
I just checked, Myron, the three
books that you will be able to talk
to Myron about or at least
to purchase are the
three he talked about.
But he has a wonderful career.
He's actually the author
of seven books.
And as we learned this
morning, most of those are based
on personal experience and he has
wonderful-- not only a messenger,
but it really personifies what
we're doing about this problem
and communicate-- improving
communication today
at the Library of Congress.
We have a second wonderful
experience ahead of us.
Harry Lang-- Dr. Harry
Lang is with us.
He's-- We thank Gallaudet
press for supporting him
and for the exhibit table
that's here that talks
about a number of his books.
He's going to be actually talking
about a new book that's still
in the works but about
to be published.
It's called "Fighting
in the Shadows,
The American Civil War
through Deaf Eyes".
And I must point out
that this afternoon,
he also will be talking a little
bit about his historical research
of that related to
this book and to--
related to his historical books.
So, this is in a sense
a prepublication event
where you are going to
learn some of the details
that are forthcoming in the book.
And we are very pleased to
have him here not for one,
but also for two appearances.
Harry Lang is not just an author and
an educator, a professor emeritus
at the National Technical
Institute for the Deaf at Rochester.
And as I said, we're very
pleased to have him here.
Let's welcome Harry Lang.
And where are you, Harry?
There you are.
>> Harry G. Lang: Good
morning everyone.
I'm very happy to be
here today with you.
It's a wonderful honor to be here.
You know I've been retired now
for five years from the position.
And I never imagined that I would
be standing in front of the Library
of Congress, the largest library in
the world, giving this presentation.
And I love libraries, you know.
When you write books, you really
hope that they'll end up there.
So, you've got to like
the-- I like libraries.
I also feel very lucky
because in the audience,
we have one of the
best editor of books,
[inaudible] Wallace here with us.
And also many of you are sure to
know the name of Michael Olson
who is also here with us today,
one of the best archivists
that we can have here
in our presence.
So again, I've been very lucky
to be working with these folks
who have been supporting me
through the books that I've written.
I also have to thank Alice
Hagemeyer and Alec McFarlane
for inviting me here and for
really getting me out of my shell,
out of warm Florida-- or hot Florida
to come up here into chilly DC.
Many of you have such
warm personalities
that I guess that's what
really finally convinced me
that the temperature would
be warm enough here today.
So this morning, I was asked
to focus on my tenth book
which is focusing on the civil war.
And this afternoon, I'm going to be
presenting again about how it was
that I used the Library of
Congress during my research
for that manuscript.
I'll be giving you more examples
from civil war book research,
but also from other books as well.
So as I said, the focus
here is going to be on the--
on deaf culture and
the deaf community.
But as I'm sure you know,
during the civil war,
the deaf community was a very
new thing for deaf people.
We're talking about 1860s of course.
The first school for the
deaf was established in 1817,
the American School for
the Deaf in Connecticut
and was just really
one very small school.
It was from there that the
deaf community was born
and propagated in the United States.
So, it was not too far in
advance of the civil war.
And we certainly see that American
Sign Language was threatened
and banned with Samuel Howell
trying to discourage students
from using sign language
just there before the war.
So, we can certainly say
from the outset of the war
that the deaf community
was struggling
as far as deaf culture went.
We did have some focus on
sign language, and I was able
to find some evidence of some deaf
artists who during the war focused
on the war and documenting
what was happening
in the American experience.
But there was really very little
that these artists were doing
about the deaf community itself.
So, I'll focus here in my talk
about that period of history
and the characters that
were involved in it.
If we could move on.
So, one thing that I learned
from 12 years of research
on the civil war was that
the deaf community was really
on the verge of crumbling.
Because of the war's politics being
so strong in the states at the time,
you know, the brotherhood
of deaf people was
really a myth at the time.
The politics of the war were
dividing people left and right,
between north and south,
black and white.
And the same things were
happening in the deaf community.
And those were some of the issues
that I faced when I wrote the book.
Really, the deaf community existed
in small pockets throughout
the United States.
And the north and south divide.
Among those pockets was very
clear in the stories that I found
that deaf people wrote conflicting
with other deaf people
in those other pockets.
Dr. Gertz talked about Gallaudet
University and the partnership
with the Library of Congress.
I actually pulled a quote
from the Jefferson Building.
If Mr. Cole is here, yeah?
Here's a quote here from
the Jefferson Building
if you're familiar with it.
Did anyone know who
made this quote famous?
It was a deaf writer in fact.
And if we go into the next
slide, we'll see who that was.
Edward Bulwer-Lytton was the
person who coined that quote.
He was deaf from a young man
and became very isolated throughout
his life because of his deafness.
But that was-- he was very
much an example of how he--
how his deafness was invisible
in the historical record.
I'll talk more this afternoon with
some stories about how the word deaf
when you search for archives comes
up with a lot of hits for the types
of stories that you
might be looking for.
So, the origins of my work
with the book started in 1984
when I was lucky to
meet Dr. Stephen Hawking
because I was a physicist myself
and the president of an organization
for scientists with disabilities.
So, Dr. Hawking actually came
here to the United States
and I was invited to
meet him at that event.
I was able to interview him there
and it was a wonderful honor.
If you look here at this
picture on the right-hand side,
you'll see that I used to have
hair at some point in my life.
It started to fade here.
But my ASL interpreter is pictured
there in the middle of the picture
and you'll see Dr. Hawking seated
in his-- in the wheelchair.
So, he has an assistant here at
the time because this was very much
at the time when-- because of
ALS taking control of his voice.
His muscle control was waning.
In the middle of the interview
that I conducted with him,
he would look up and try
to speak for himself.
But sometimes, his assistant
would have to intervene,
listen to what he was trying
to say and repeat his response
so that the ASL interpreter
could then translate the message.
But at one point, he said, you know,
it must be difficult to be deaf.
And I said, yeah, you know, I
like to play tennis and, you know,
we've all got some
struggles in life,
things that prevent
us from doing things.
And so, I think that really
inspired me in my research
when I went back to Rochester.
If we can move on?
To do what I call NIH research,
who can tell me what NIH means?
OK. So, we've got a
guess from the audience
that this means the National
Institutes of Health.
No, you're wrong there.
No. No, that's not at all
what I mean by NIH research.
My definition of NIH research,
if we can have it on the screen,
is Needle in a Haystack Research.
If you're familiar with the
adage, it means that when I go
to the library, you know, I'd look
at a barrage of science books.
And in some ways, the only way for
finding the things that I'm looking
for is to read through them and look
for the word deaf because this type
of research is not easy to do.
There is really very little
published on deaf scientists
when I began my research.
I went to France at one point and
tried to find the word school.
I read through German books
looking for the words--
the German words for deaf.
And one by one, I was able to
find things luckily and found
over 3000 mentions of deaf
scientists throughout history.
But really, this traces
back to my meeting
with Dr. Hawking and
his inspiration.
There are different approaches
to writing biographies.
The first book, "Silence of
the Spheres", which is history
of science from a deaf perspective.
It shows a history of deaf
people, both women and men,
who had been successful in science.
But their stories are
unfortunately not shared very much.
And I was lucky to
find their stories
and publish them into that book.
The second book is "Deaf Persons
in the Arts and Sciences".
This has different biographies, more
in depth than the first publication.
Next one is "A Phone of Our Own".
This is about the invention
of the TTY.
And I'm sure some of the--
us here in the audience,
especially our last
speaker, remember us growing
up without any access
to a telephone.
And it was really the deaf
community fighting for the rights
to use a telephone that--
against AT&T who had refused
to help us in the community.
That caused us to invent
our own machine, the TTY.
An interesting story that I
learned from that research is
that many deaf people who
really loved deaf culture
and really loved the ownership
of the TTY also had kept in mind
that the TTY was developed
by three oral deaf people.
These were members of the
Alexander Graham Bell Foundation
who developed the TTY.
And so, there was some, you
know, tension in knowing
that this machine was
invented by non-signers.
And throughout the book
here, we confront the issues
of these people not being
signers and their membership
in the Alexander Graham Bell
Foundation and how ownership
of the TTY actually came in the form
of collaboration between
AG Bell and NAD.
It was when the Alexander Graham
Bell Foundation invited NAD members
to a meeting to show
off the technology.
And it was at that point
where we saw this sort
of landmark collaboration between
non-signing and signing members
of the deaf community
to develop the TTY.
So, I think it was proof
that in collaboration
between these two parts of
the community, you know,
important collaborations and
innovations can take shape.
Mr. Sanderson from the National
Association of the Deaf saw how
that event could move into
other spheres, like education
and cooperation that these two
organizations could bring to light.
So, here's another book about Robert
Panara, if you're familiar with him,
a good friend of 40 years.
He was very successful both in the
hearing world and in the deaf world.
And Bob Davila, also a good friend
of mine and also a very skilled user
of Spanish, a trilingual person, I
was able to read a book about him.
Here's another one about really
my research on the Civil War
when one night I was reading an
unpublished manuscript that was
of good size, looking
back at Edmund Booth.
So, he was reminiscing about
his children in this document.
And his son remembered
that one night, working--
sitting with his mom who was deaf
and several hearing children,
his father, Mr. Booth, came home
from working at the newspaper
to tell his family that Abraham
Lincoln had been assassinated.
So I have a quote here from his
son, if you go into the next slide,
that says that, "His
face was white and stern.
The lines about his mouth were set
and his eye expressed both
deep anger and sorrow."
That quote really made me think,
how was it that deaf people
lived during the civil war?
I wondered what they did, how
they got involved in the war.
Next slide please.
So, I had the story of this one
deaf man and he was very involved
in the war I should I say.
He was an editorial
writer in his life.
He had many hearing soldiers
in the war he corresponded with
and he would publish
their stories in his--
a newspaper from Anamosa., Iowa.
He published their stories there
and really called them friends.
He considered them
very close companions.
But his life was threatened
several times because he fought
with copperheads, you know, the
peace democrats at the time.
He hated them, they hated him.
On the streets, they would confront
each other and get in some scuffles
and they would write
notes back and forth.
And Edmund Booth's
daughter wrote that his--
her father who was deaf
was-- had a very mighty pen,
much mightier than the sword.
And she felt that he
did more for the Union
than any soldier potentially
had done rather
than potentially the exception
of Grant Lee or Sheridan.
So these newspapers
would copy his editorials
and publish them across the nation.
So, this raised the
question of, you know,
I wanted to continue
my NIH research to see
if there were more deaf
people that I could find
who had been engaged in the war.
I didn't really find
anything, any specific book
that was the talked-about deaf
people's involvements in the war.
I did briefly find a few articles
that mentioned a woman by the name
of Laura Redden who had
written several things.
I found one website that said
there had been no soldiers
who were deaf in the civil war.
But I was skeptical of that truth
and didn't accept it for my own.
So, I continued my NIH research.
And I felt like that was really
the only way to go about this,
this journey to find who was deaf
and involved in the civil war.
In the area of writing, you know,
fighting with the pen, if you will,
I found that deaf writers
and deaf newspaper editors,
deaf poets were somewhat prevalent.
I found a deaf diarist as well.
Deaf people corresponded with
each other in letter form.
So, we were lucky to find a lot of
documentation about their thoughts
and how it was that they
were believing in the cause
of either the north or the
south through what they wrote.
There's also fighting
with the sword.
I found several stories
of deaf soldiers, many.
Some of whom joined the north, some
of whom joined the south and some
who fought and died, some who
weren't accepted into the army
because of the medical
test that ruled them
out where the doctors would refuse
to admit profoundly deaf
people into the core.
Although, they would often
accept hard of hearing people,
but they would try to, you know,
limit them to saying that deaf--
that hard of hearing
people wouldn't know
from which side an
enemy was approaching.
And so, a lot of issues came up when
I was finding these deaf soldiers.
And the theme was that hard
of hearing soldiers were more
prevalent than deaf soldiers.
Among those who were accepted into
the armies, they were often assigned
to noncombatant roles like
clerks or horse care or cooks
and not many fought, although there
were some stories there as well.
There were a lot of stories
about hearing men who became deaf
as a result of their service in the
army, tens of thousands who fought
and who through injuries
became deaf.
And so, I think that that was
actually an interesting experience
to read about because you could
see how they had to adjust
to the deaf world,
but at the same time,
fight for their own
lives and survival.
So, I saw many experiences that
popped up through my research
where these people who were
born hearing began to understand
that there was this new balance in
their lives, that they were living
with tinnitus or for those of
you who are deaf like myself,
learning that vibrations
can mean something to you,
like that there's a loud noise
somewhere, either far away
or closer depending on the type
of vibrations that you feel.
So, these people were learning to
gain these feels in their lives
as a result of becoming deaf.
And that, you know, eventually
would actually help them in battle
if they decided to continue on.
I think the most interesting thing
for me was when the war was actually
over and seeing the stories that
emerged there, seeing the tens
of thousands of hearing
men who became deaf
who did not receive pensions equal
to those who had other disabilities
that they sustained during the war.
These men actually formed an
organization called the Silent Army.
And the Silent Army fought
the United States government
for equal pension pay as other--
as people with other
types of disabilities.
And we can actually thank the
Library of Congress for that
because the Library of
Congress has a book in fact
in its archives called "The Silent
Army" with 101 actual stories
of people who became deaf
during the Civil War and later
on could not get jobs because
of the attitudes that existed
within hearing communities and
the new issues that cropped
up around communication
with family and colleagues.
Some of you have who have-- who live
here may have visited Fort Defense--
Fort Stevens rather.
It's here in DC on Georgia Avenue.
So if any of you have seen it,
you might be familiar with it.
For those of you who are not, Fort
Stevens has a very interesting story
that I'll share with you here today.
I'll use a quote that I mentioned
before that some people--
some deaf people had joined militias
because they couldn't actually
be accepted to the official army
so they joined instead militia
organizations to protect the towns
when the enemy combatants
were approaching.
Sometimes the armies, you know,
weren't readily available.
So, civilians had to fight
the wars for themselves.
So, this is the story of
an 11-year-old deaf boy
who was a gardener in
fact in his community
with a woman whose husband
was an admiral in the US Navy,
and she wrote letters to
her husband about this--
about what was going
on in her hometown.
And when the south was approaching
and attacking Washington, DC,
Fort Stevens was the only battle
that President Lincoln had
actually observed in person.
So, he actually came to the area.
The soldiers warned him that
he shouldn't stand up because
as he was very tall, they were
worried that he would be a target.
That was the only battle as I said
that Lincoln was there
for in person.
But at any rate, the soldiers
were there, they were talking
about that the president was there.
But they actually more talked
about this 11-year-old deaf boy
who stole a rifle from the
woman that he was working
as a gardener whose husband was
the admiral and joined the battle
and killed six rebels
in the process.
Can you imagine an
11-year-old deaf boy doing this?
And I have-- Anyway, I have a quote
from her letter, that the woman
that he was working for, to her
husband describing the situation.
She says, "The soldiers say
that he killed some five
or six Rebel sharpshooters.
I do not like to think of anyone
so young taking the
lives of so many men.
But this young gardener
of mine is no common boy
and has shown marked
character from infancy."
So, there are other quotes that
document most of the story.
And the book that I'm writing now
has about 200 stories in total
that talk about deaf people's
involvements in the civil war,
begets involvement with
pen or with the sword.
I'm not sure if any of you have
read the fictional story called
"Chickamauga".
But this story is a
story about a young boy.
And in the story, he
plays with a wood sword.
He goes out into the woods.
And during the battle
of Chickamauga,
the deaf boy didn't hear the fact
that there was shooting going
on around him, continued to play.
But he started to see some wounded
and crippled soldiers down on hands
and knees from their battle wounds.
This young boy actually climbs
up and rides on one of the horses
that had been-- with
one of the soldiers.
And so at first you think,
goodness, this is so funny.
This kid is so nave to believe
that the area is safe
despite what he sees.
He actually ends up falling
asleep in the middle of the battle
and wakes up to see a
light off in a distance.
He follows it and finds that his
farmhouse has been burned down
and he finds that his
mother is dead now.
At the end of the story, it turns
out that the child was a deaf
mute child as the story goes.
A bit of a surprise ending for me,
I read that and thought to myself,
it seems like this is one of a
very few stories that we can find
of deaf children's experience
in the world-- in the war.
And I think that it was interesting
that they would portray this child
as nave because we can
see throughout the stories
that I've found that deaf children
have very much been involved
in the war and all aspects of it.
In one school for the deaf, the deaf
children made 1.5 million bullets
for the southern army.
Now, if you would--
if you're a teacher,
anyone here on the audience,
I'm not sure that you
would allow deaf children
to play with gunpowder.
But this school for the
deaf supported their--
the southern army and they also
made confederate money as well there
because they had a print
shop in the school.
So, they were able to print
money for the southern states.
They also made flags to support
their army depending on what--
you know, where-- what states
these deaf schools were in.
Some of the girls would be
assigned to sew up uniforms.
The boys would be assigned
to make boots.
And the kids in school wrote
about war time events as well.
I just met somebody
from Kentucky here.
I found that after the battle
of Berryville in Kentucky,
there were hundreds and hundreds
of dead bodies just
strewn about the field.
All the soldiers had to leave
so that they could go
fight other battles.
So, they went to the
Kentucky School for the Deaf
and they asked the children
there to help bury the dead.
They said there were about 300
dead bodies after that battle.
So, those children were
certainly not nave at all,
they were very aware from their help
in that situation of
death and dying.
You know, also keep in mind that
there were a lot of deaf children
who saw the deaths of their
fathers, brothers, friends,
neighbors throughout the war.
Let's talk a little bit more about
the National Literary Society
for the Deaf and the context
of what I'm talking about here.
As we mentioned before,
it was founded in 1907.
And I thought that it was
an interesting coincidence
that 40 years before that,
many schools for the deaf had their
own literary societies embedded
within the schools.
So, one example of this is the
Kentucky School for the Deaf
in which I found the
minutes from their meetings
in a manuscript that's shown here.
It's called "The Minute Book
of the Deaf Mute Society
of the Kentucky Institution
for the Deaf and Dumb."
So, I read through it.
And these kids were heavily involved
on a weekly basis in debates,
debates on topics that were
really pertinent to the civil war.
One question was, was
President Lincoln right
in declaring war on
the seceding states?
Another debate was on the
bombardment of Fort Henry.
And there were multiple other topics
that were found here in this book.
And it certainly was not isolated
to the Kentucky School for the Deaf
or to debate groups but
also to newspapers as well.
The American School for the Deaf,
I'm sure you're all familiar
with this, they-- celebrating
200 years coming
up here pretty soon in 2018.
Some people are hoping that the post
[inaudible] is going to commemorate
that anniversary with
a special stamp
to honor the American
School for the Deaf.
At any rate, ASD is a
very fascinating place.
Before the war, there
were many abolitionists,
people who opposed slavery
who were teachers at that ASD,
including Thomas Hopkins Gallaudet,
Lewis Weld after him and so on.
Edmund Booth was a
teacher there as well.
So, the list of well-known
deaf names is quite long.
The school had kids from the south
actually there before the war.
And because there were
famous abolitionists in the--
you know, on the teaching
staff or had been invited,
Lewis Weld being one of them, was
surprised to find that deaf kinds
in Hartford, Connecticut where
ASD is located really proved all
of his beliefs on slavery, all of
his writings on slavery, you know,
where obviously controversial
to southern children
who had come from plantations.
And so, the deaf northern
children had published articles
that were supporting these
abolitionists' views and some
of those actually included the
children from the southern states.
Here's a newspaper for
the deaf community.
And it talks about
"Boys in the Battle
of Shiloh" and "The Dying Soldier".
So again, schools for the deaf were
encouraging deaf schools to read
about the war and to
write about it as well.
This is coming from the North
Carolina School at Raleigh.
Some teachers during the war who
were not involved during the war,
continue to advocate
the deaf children
to read about what was going on.
And I really love this quote.
It says, "Let every parent who has
a deaf child encourage his child
to read and write.
Be up and act, ye who give birth
to children of eternal silence.
Be not weary in this good work."
I thought it was a really beautiful
quote that shows, you know,
the 1860 mentality of a teacher
from Philadelphia who believed
that it was of utmost importance
that parents be involved
in the lives of deaf
children and their education.
Here's a deaf artist
that I mentioned before.
Imagine during the middle of
the Civil War with the country--
the future of country at
stake and certainly uncertain
and generally sitting
back posing for a portrait
by this deaf artist right
in the middle of the war.
Now, he was not the
only one to do this,
Stonewall Jackson did similarly.
He sat for a portrait by
a deaf artist as well.
This is the famous John Mosby.
Mosby was a terrorist
of sorts at the time.
He killed many civilians and
actually sat for a portrait
by this the same deaf artist.
On the right-hand side here,
I'm showing a lithograph
of the 10th Massachusetts Regiment.
And you see the man who's
sitting on the far right
on the right bottom
corner who's painting.
It's been enlarged in the inset.
That is the deaf artist who's
also a soldier in this instance.
So again, you see that
enlargement there in the corner.
And Gallaudet University has
a copy of this lithograph
as this Library of Congress.
There are a myriad of stories of
deaf soldiers who are wounded.
Unfortunately, we don't
have many pictures
of these soldiers who are wounded.
But I do have a picture of
the battle that was pertinent
to the discussion here which
a man from the Virginia School
for the Deaf joined the army.
And this, I recently
found in the library
in Virginia among stacks
of old papers.
Going through them, I
found the enlistment record
of this man among other soldiers
obviously within the companies.
And so, this deaf man by the name
of Berkeley [assumed
spelling] is mentioned there.
They actually list
him as deaf and mute.
So, you know, these are the ways in
which I'm trying to find evidence
of deaf people's involvements in the
civil war to include in the book,
so finding things all
over the place.
So to try to summarize the
research that I was able to do,
there were deaf doctors, deaf
nurses, photographers, farmers,
carpenters, shipbuilders, sword
makers and I'd like to say,
you know, 10 or 15 deaf people who
were really involved in spycraft.
So, really, some fascinating stories
that, you know, unfortunately,
can't give you [inaudible]
but the book has, like I said,
over 200 stories of
these fascinating men
and women who are involved.
Schools for the deaf were large--
they were sometimes destroyed during
battles, for example in Missouri
and Mississippi, the battles really,
really destroyed these schools
bringing them down to the ground.
During the siege of
Jackson, that was one time
when a school was burnt down.
Many of the people were killed,
just simply walking by, you know,
and enemy soldiers would come by
and see them and try to stop them
but because they didn't
hear them and kept walking,
they would shoot them dead.
Deaf slaves also, were part of
this, deaf slave owners as well.
Deaf slave catchers.
So, you know, when a slave would
escape, the slave catchers would try
to find these people and bring
them back to their owners
and there were some deaf people
among their ranks as well.
So, as I mentioned, just recently,
I'm nearing the end of my story,
but I'd like you to sit back
and imagine the abolitionist
that I mentioned before,
Mr. Garrison.
Now, he was involved in the
American School for the Deaf
and there were some children there
who supported the institution
of slavery and some were against it.
Imagine John Wilkes Booth,
who killed Abraham Lincoln,
but just before that had a deaf
woman friend and invited her
to teach him how to
write love sonnets
for his fianc, how to sign them.
So, an interesting story about John
Wilkes Booth who's brother wrote a
letter to this woman saying
that he's been struggling
to learn the alphabet
and other signs.
And then, John Wilkes
Booth's sister, Asia Booth,
also started learning
sign language as well.
Now, I doubt very much if the
deaf woman poet who was associated
with Mr. Booth knew of his plans to
kill the president because no one
in his family actually
know about that.
Imagine also a deaf soldier who was
wounded on the battlefield and had
to amputate his own
leg before he died.
Imagine a French prince who came
to the United States to meet
with President Lincoln and
Lincoln assigned that prince
and his two nephews,
who are both hearing,
to work with General
McClellan throughout, you know,
eight or nine months period of
time in the peninsula campaign.
There were deaf people
of all sorts involved
in the civil war in different ways.
This deaf prince will actually come
back up this afternoon in my talk
about research and the type of
research that I was able to do here
in the Library of Congress
to author my book.
He was an interesting character.
He had several servants, four
or five men, who followed him
around to support him in
the work that he was doing.
So in all, this-- my 10th book,
really shows the amazing involvement
of deaf people in many
different ways in the civil war.
We, deaf people, were involved
in determining the future
of our country, and I think
that that becomes an important
message as you read the book.
Now, you know, the title
says the word shadows,
and I think I should talk a little
bit about what I mean by that.
When you read about the civil
war, you read about Lee and Grant
and Sheridan, you read about
a lot of hearing people.
You may hear about hearing writers
like Walt Whitman and others
but you don't read
about deaf writers
who really wrote beautiful poems
and other pieces that contributed
to the literary history
of America at the time.
Well, we're talking about people
who grew up deaf but were able
to express themselves quite
eloquently in written form.
So, I think that it's appropriate
that we talk about fighting
in the shadows, because, really,
those people were not recognized
for their work at the
time, but through the book,
I'm hoping to bring these
personalities into the light
and much more into the
mainstream of our history.
So, thank you very much
again for inviting me here
for allowing me to speak.
[ Applause ]
Nice job.
>> John Cole: Well, thank
you very much Harry,
this really has gotten us off to
a wonderful start and I'm happy
to report-- I was fuzzing
a little bit whether all
of the books would arrive,
and they have arrived.
So, we have more books for
sale than I originally thought.
And you'll have a chance to talk
with the authors, get books signed,
and we're going to take a break
until we reconvene at 1:15.
But, let me explain,
the cafeteria is next--
practically is next door if you
keep walking through this door,
this is one end of this
beautiful cafeteria,
which is where I hope you'll enjoy
each other and have something to eat
in order to come back
for the other program.
I have to share a little
excitement with you.
The Library of Congress-- The
Librarian of Congress is appointed
by the President of the United
States and confirmed by the Senate.
And this means that it doesn't
happen very often, but we are--
now have a nominee to be the Library
of Congress, the new librarian.
Dr. James Billington, who
came after Daniel Boorstin,
who I talked about
as being our founder,
Dr. Boorstin was the
librarian form 1975 until 1987.
He was nominated by President Ford.
Dr. Billington, James Billington,
a Russian historian was nominated--
when Dr. Boorstin resigned, he
was an author, and still working
on a wonderful set of books called
"The Americans", he resigned.
President Reagan nominated James
Billington, who became a librarian
in 1987 and he retired last year.
And now, President Obama
has nominated Carla Hayden
who is the director of libraries
at the Hayden-- Pratt library.
And she will be the first
female and the first Black,
African-American Librarian
of Congress.
And we've been fuzzing, worrying
about hearings that are coming up,
because if you know the news, the
US Senate isn't exactly excited
about holding nominations for
the Supreme Court nominee,
but nothing has been said.
And we've had our fingers crossed
that there will be
hearings for Carla Hayden.
And I had to leave for a moment
because she's just stopped
by the center for the book, which is
on this floor, to say hello to me.
And I got back in time
to close this.
But what I asked for her, I
said, "Are there hearings?"
And she said, "Yes, people
aren't talking about it,
but they're holding them next week."
And so, that's very good news
for the Library of Congress.
And, I think, very good news for
outreach and for-- she's a former--
she's a public librarian and
director of the Enoch Pratt Library.
So, and I ask her if
she wanted to come down
and say something-- say hello.
And she said, no, she's
here on the QT, slightly.
But it's obviously dropping
by and seeing people.
So, that is a wonderful way to,
I think, chat, to break things
and is good news for us, I think,
at the Library of Congress.
And she did know about
the literary society.
She actually checked
with the schedule
and saw that I was here today.
And she said, she's very happy with
the endorsements that she's getting
from all parts of the library
and literacy community.
And so, I feel that we
will have a friend--
not that we haven't had a friend,
but we will have a special friend
in the office of the
Librarian of Congress.
Now, I didn't mention also, the
cafeteria is right through there,
restrooms are right out here.
If you want to make a trip to the
Jefferson Building, I'm afraid,
we have-- those things are
preoccupied with other groups.
But we have a self guide
that you could take.
And if you would like to go, I would
be happy to get people there and--
but you would need to
come back on your own.
So, perhaps, if we wanted to do
that, someone who's already been
to the Jefferson Building
could actually serve as a guide
with a small group of
people who wanted to go.
And I would get you there
and the person who went
with us could get you back.
But-- And we would give
you a copy of the guide
to the Jefferson Building which
shows you some things you could see.
It's a little tight, I have to
tell you, to go through the tunnel
and to come back in time
for-- to be back at 1:15.
And it would not really leave
you time for a leisurely lunch,
probably, you would
have to skip lunch.
I'm sorry about that.
But if someone wants to do
that, I'll be happy to get--
at least get you over there.
But I think, we should close
with really, a round of applause
for the speakers this morning
and they've all been wonderful
and we've gotten ourselves
off to a great start.
Thank you very much.
See you back here at 1:15.
Thank you.
This afternoon's program is
going to be a little less formal,
not that we were formal this
morning, but this is conceived more
as a workshop with several
different presentations
on several different topics that
relate to our overall concern
about the deaf culture
in our society,
and particularly in libraries.
And we're going to begin
with a presentation--
sorry, I'm getting my
program turned around,
Chaim is here from
the Copyright Office.
And he is going to talk a little
bit about copyright and fair use.
Chaim Levinson has been
in the Copyright Office,
which is part of the
Library of Congress for--
he tells me, for five years.
And his presentation is going
to be geared towards our
interest in copyright.
But he also will tell you a
little bit about what fair use is
and why it's important
in our context.
So, Chaim, please take over.
Thank you.
>> Chaim Levinson: My
name is Chaim Levinson.
I work in the Copyright Office on
the fourth floor of this building.
I work in the department of
records-- recording-- recordation.
It's a big responsibility
that I have.
But I want to start with
a question for you all.
Do you all know the difference
between a patent and copyright?
It seems like that's a stumpy
audience, but I'll be here
to share the information with you.
So, a patent protects
things and inventions,
things that are physical in nature.
So, a patent can protect anything
that has that physical nature to it.
Copyright, on the other hand,
is a little bit different.
The concept is roughly the same--
-- but it talks about things
that are not physical.
So, for instance, a song has
no physical nature to it.
Music, can be notated on paper,
certainly, something that we can see
and has physical notation to it.
A copyright protects what it is
that you see on the printed page.
So, the ideas that
are written down on
to the paper is what copyright
can protect Here at the Library
of Congress, our responsibility is
to protect your ideas as you sit
down and create new works of art by
writing words on a piece of paper,
that work can become
protected under copyright.
So, you may be curious how it is
that you can protect your work
and yourself when you
create these works of art.
There are several processes that
we have, one being registration,
and in my department, in
the recording department--
-- is where we do that work.
I would like to give
you some examples here--
-- of useful works.
A useful work is anything that
you create, it can be a machine,
anything with a use--
with a moving part.
So, for example, computers, mobile
phones, household appliances
and other types of machinery.
These all fall under the
category of useful works.
These are things that you
can use for your self,
for your own personal benefit.
Things that are made
or manufactured.
On the other hand, created--
creative or intellectual
works incorporate things
such as books, music and art.
Jewelry also falls
into this category
and many other things as well.
So copyright is used to
protect these types of works.
At the most simple or basic level--
-- what do you think
copyright may mean to you?
Imagine that you're at home
and you're writing a
letter to your mother.
The moment that you lift
the pen from the page,
that letter becomes protected under
a copyright, it belongs to you.
It means that it's your property.
It can't belong to anyone
else, it can't belong to me
and I have no rights to copy
that, nor does anyone else.
That letter is your property.
Now, through the registration
process here at the Library
of Congress, that letter can
be registered as your property
because it belongs to you.
And if anyone wanted
to use that letter,
they would be required
to get your permission.
So, that then becomes
your right to copyright.
So, in my department,
my responsibility is
to provide citizens
certificates indicating
that that property
actually belongs to you.
And if that anyone wants
to steal your work,
you would be legally protected
to sue that person for damages.
So that puts that right
in black and white.
So, there was a question
here in the audience.
That's written down
in black and white.
On a piece of paper, showing
that this is your property,
that's correct.
So, if you make jewelry, if you
take a picture of it and show it
in the registration office here,
that will go into the certificate
and into the copyright, rights
that are afforded to you.
Now, this topic is very broad.
I can only provide you with a
very surface level interpretation
of what it means--
-- because most of this
process involves a lot
of legal obligation,
and I am no lawyer.
So, my ability to explain the
process in depth is limited.
Imagine, if you will, that you're
an actor and you write a play.
That work belongs to you and
you therefore own the copyright.
The works can be creative,
expressive, that can be poetry,
song, art work, anything
that you see
in picture format can be
protected under copyright.
And I hope that's clear for you.
Hopefully so.
Great.
Now, when you want to
register for a copyright--
-- your copyright will actually
have a very long lifespan.
In fact, that copyright
can last over 70 years.
And anyone who wants to use that
work will require your permission
without exception, otherwise,
that would be considered stealing.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Question from the audience, when
is the copyright no longer valid?
That's a very good question.
I can't say for sure,
because I know, first of all,
that it is over 70 years.
But you can add periods of 25
or 50 years depending
on the circumstances.
So, it can go on for
a very long time.
So, in the same way that patents can
be extended, copyright can as well.
Question from the audience, can that
be passed down to a family member
since it's the person's property?
My understanding is that, through
a legal process, you can do that.
But no one else has the right to
use your work unless that is--
that happens because
your name is on it.
So, is it a lifetime copyright?
That's the answer.
Another question from the audience.
>> When you have a copyright,
essentially, that copyright can last
for over 70 years or
lifelong, really.
There is a book, for example,
if it is under a copyright,
then that book, in theory,
can be yours forever?
>> Chaim Levinson: Yes.
It will last, unless you
decide, through a legal process,
that your wishes are otherwise
and you make that very clear
that you would allow another use.
But yes, it would continue but
there's a time in which it would end
and become what is called,
in the public domain.
And what that means is that at that
point, anyone is free to use it.
So, yes, your copyright can
be renewed but you have to go
through the correct legal
processes to do that.
>> So, is there any time
limit to a copyright?
>> Chaim Levinson: Not as
long as you're living, no.
That property belongs
to you and you alone.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> And if the copyright legal owner
passes away then they can pass
that right on to someone else?
>> Chaim Levinson: Again,
through legal methods, yes.
>> What about material
that's put online?
Do the same rights apply?
>> Chaim Levinson: Now, that
question is actually beyond my role.
As I said, I'm able to talk
about the copyright process
on a rather surface level.
But any questions that go beyond
that knowledge would probably best
be answered by a copyright lawyer.
And copyright law is a
complex thing to understand.
And someone better versed in it
would be able to explain that to you
or someone in the office
in which I work.
>> I have an additional question.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
I just have a person in mind.
Let's say an individual
named John wrote a song.
And this person named John
has a copyright on that song
and let's say, for instance
someone who wasn't aware
that that song existed
had used that song
that was originally made by John.
If John took legal action
for theft of his property,
would it be in the best
interest of that other person
to avoid getting sued to
research and make sure
that they have a right
to use that song?
>> Chaim Levinson: Well,
that is a very good question.
Well, so during the
certification process,
you would have a certificate
that's given to you.
And in the registration, it would
claim that that is indeed your work.
What then happens is
that is transferred
over to my department
and we record that fact.
That's all uploaded to our database
system for tracking purposes.
So, if another person comes
up with the same idea,
copyright law will protect you
saying that this work belongs to you
but it does not decide who it
belongs to but there is a process
that would be made clear to
you what actually belongs
to you in that situation.
So, you don't really have to
be afraid of the ramifications,
you can be confident
that any creative work
that you make has been
recorded correctly
and that we will protect
you through that.
Any other questions
from the audience?
Yeah? I love questions.
>> So, I'm going to pick
on you here a little bit.
>> Chaim Levinson: Yeah, no worries.
>> So, for a copyright--
-- is that required to be on set?
>> Is that what he said?
>> Chaim Levinson: A concept
is what you're asking?
>> I'm sorry, concrete,
I meant to say.
Does that apply to something that's
concrete such as a piece of paper?
An example that I have in mind, for
example, if I made a song about,
you know, my love for birds,
for me, that's my right.
However, if there's
no documentation,
does my copyright still exist?
>> Chaim Levinson: Right.
So you actually have to record that.
You have to put it down on some
medium and when you're done,
when you're finished with
the work at that moment is
when it becomes protected
under copyright.
>> OK. So, you're saying, in order
for you to have that copyright,
whatever that song is, has to
be noted on concrete paper?
>> Chaim Levinson: Yeah.
It has to be in physical form.
But it can, you know,
be a voice recording
or anything else like that.
It can be a video of
the performance.
But it has to be original work and
it has to show that it's yours.
It can't be anybody else's.
Once you establish that, from that
point on, you don't have to worry
about it being used by anyone else.
>> Thank you for lessening
my worries.
And if you were to write
something on paper,
would it have to be in pen?
>> Chaim Levinson: Oh, no.
No, you could write it with
a feather if you wanted.
I do it all the time.
I write in calligraphy quite a lot.
So, anything that you do,
for example, if it's art,
something that you've
created yourself,
anything that you establish
in a physical form
that belongs to you
can be protected.
The next step is to register it.
So, our job is to record it,
to input that in our system
and to provide you with
the certificate, again,
that shows that that work is yours.
So, if there's any competitor
to you, we can come back
to the original submission
and you can show proof
that this work is actually yours
and has been registered
through my office.
I hope that's clear for everyone.
>> So, the copyright is
really based on a date, right?
>> Chaim Levinson:
Yeah, that's part of it.
So, through the registration office,
we will examine what has
been submitted and decide
if that is really able to
receive copyright or not and then,
we'll let you know what
the decision is from then.
Because some things are not covered
under the concept of copyright,
I'll give you an example
of some things.
A fashion designer could
not copyright cloth.
If, however, there was
art on the garment,
then that could be copyrighten
[phonetic], but not cloth.
The design on the paper-- of
the garment can be copyrighten
but the cloth form of it cannot be.
>> So, let's suppose that
I had ideas on a paper
that I have copyrighted, and
then, several weeks later,
someone else has tried to submit
a document with the same ideas
and they get a copyright,
how would you determine
who actually owns that copyright?
Would you go back to
the date of submission?
>> Chaim Levinson: It always
depends on who's first.
And sometimes, that happens.
If several people come up with the
same idea around the same time,
when you come to the registration
office, a group of lawyers
who are employed by the office
will decide who would win
out if those have all been submitted
roughly around the same time.
So, there is a priority for time.
Not everyone who would submit means
that their idea is actually original
and that's why we employ that
group of lawyers to decide
who had the original idea.
So they are employed by our office
to make those types of decisions.
Some people come up with
ideas that are really vague.
I mean, they probably
just went on the internet
and stole those ideas
from other authors.
>> I'm actually going to sit
and ask my question from here.
There was a situation
that I was made aware
of where two people having
a conversation on the phone
and somewhat submitted
an idea claiming
that they were the first one
to come up with this idea,
but really, it was someone else.
>> Chaim Levinson: OK.
So, from the perspective of my
office, when I provide someone
with a certificate, that includes
documentation and also the number
of the certificate
that appears on it.
The registration and
documentation offices work together
to support you 100% of the
way regarding your work,
to help you determine
what belongs to you.
At that point, you don't
really have to worry
about other people competing with
you because you have that proof
of what it is that we are
saying belongs to you.
At that point, it doesn't
matter what anyone else may have
because that is not
valid under the law.
We are saying that it
is indeed that your idea
and that you have the rights to it.
>> I actually have
two questions for you.
The first question is, are blogs
recognized under copyright?
>> Chaim Levinson: I
really can't speak to that.
So, if it's on the internet, to me,
that means that it's
in the public domain.
It's been released to
be shared by everyone.
If, however, your ideas
originated on physical paper,
that would be a very
different story.
And it's then that the
lawyers can help you
out in making that determination.
Publishing on the internet is
not generally a good source.
>> Thank you.
And my second question is for
those of us who sign on video,
why is that not recognized
under copyright?
>> Chaim Levinson: If it's in
video format and we can tell
that it's your work, like
potentially seeing you in it.
So, for example, movies are
protected by copyright law.
>> I'm referring to more of
a blog, like a video blog
of someone signing their thoughts
on video as oppose to a movie.
>> Chaim Levinson: In this case,
I'd have to ask you if you wanted
to talk more with a lawyer
to feel more comfortable
about that determination.
So, if you did that, they would
give you a more professional answer
than I could provide with you here.
So, that is the reason why we
have the registration office here
at the Library of Congress
to be able to ask--
answer those very specific
questions that you may have.
Copyright law can be very general
and also very legal in nature,
very complicated sometimes.
So that's why we provide those
lawyers to help support you
and answer your questions.
>> Thank you.
>> Chaim Levinson: All right.
>> John Cole: You have
time for one more question
if there's another question.
>> Chaim Levinson:
OK, my friend here.
>> I actually just saw
Alice's statement earlier
and she made a good point.
If someone does have a similar idea,
and they attempt to get the idea
under copyright, and they happen
to go and try to get the copyright
and the idea I made originally
because I don't have a chance
to make it in there as soon as they
do, do they still get the copyright,
although, I came up
with the idea first?
>> Chaim Levinson: So, if yours
gets approved, then it's yours.
It has nothing to do
with the other person.
>> So, essentially, you would
have to be the first one
to arrive physically
to get your copyright.
>> Chaim Levinson: Mm-hmm.
And the team would decide with you
if that work was a true
copyright, so to say.
>> Thank you very much.
Great job with your information.
>> Thank you.
>> John Cole: Thank you.
Well, you opened up interesting
questions, series of questions.
And if we're-- As I said before,
we just had an introduction
to not only copyright and fair
use but especial implications
for the world that
we're talking about now.
And I want to thank Chaim for
a straightforward presentation
and now you know the Copyright
Office, which is filled
with brochures and lawyers
and a place that you can call.
There's a copyright phone line
you can call and get information.
It's a good source and it's also--
there are some controversies
sometimes about whether
or not copyright should be
in the Library of Congress,
in most countries it's an
executive office agency.
But Chaim actually, sort
of showed you the balance
of having both the legal
responsibility and concern
about author's rights in the
digital age and counterbalanced
by these magnificent
collections that we have.
And we are also trying to make
as freely available as we can.
So, the Library of Congress
walks a tight line as well.
And I think that that balances
an attempt to look at both sides.
And in that way, I'm glad that
we have a chance at the Library
of Congress to perform that role
in American society and culture.
As I said, we're going to
have several workshop kinds
of presentations that are
different from each other.
But we're going back
to Harry Lang again.
But as you've already heard
him this morning talking
about his wonderful books,
today, he's putting--
this afternoon, he's putting on
his researcher's hat and he's going
to talk a little bit more about
resources at the Library of Congress
and the use that he has
made resources in his work.
So, let's welcome him back.
Harry, there you are.
[ Applause ]
>> Harry G. Lang: Well,
hello again everyone.
I'm wondering, how many of you
have some experience with googling
on the Library of Congress website?
Can I get a show of hands?
Has anyone here who has a great
deal of experience show of hands?
Well, I have to disclose,
I am not an expert.
I'm an example of a person
who frequently uses the
Library of Congress.
The Library of Congress
contain not only books
but also other articles published
by college professors along
with presentations similar
to what you're seeing today
that often give you a lot
of in depth information.
If you could please
move forward two slides.
The Library of Congress I mostly
use for science, education,
and deaf history, however, I have to
say that I found many other things
such as photographs, letters,
et cetera that are related
to deaf history, which I
didn't happen to use today,
but I like to give you some examples
and four strategies that were used.
Now, I was asked to
share my perspective.
And my perspective is really from
a college professor who is involved
in training teachers for many years.
Often, I don't write for children,
I find myself writing
for the adult crowd.
And particularly, adults
who have experience working
with children can glean information
from what I publish in order
to provide that information
to their students.
So, my point in saying that is that,
I might not fit all age groups.
Very rarely, I write material for
children, but again, high school,
college aged students are
typically my target audience.
Even though I am retired, I still
have a burning desire in my heart
to inspire young deaf children.
There are many biographies
written related to deaf children,
speaking from their first-person
perspective about their experience
as a child and what inspirations
they had and ultimately,
how their desire for them to reach
for the star has allowed them
to continue their work in writing,
in searching for other ways
to continue inspiring
younger people.
So, there are many wonderful stories
that are out there, many on the web,
and some you might not
have even imagined.
Very surprising what
you may find online.
Now, I would like to
discuss four strategies.
The first of the four
include browsing.
For example, searching
for the word deaf.
And this concept is actually
more complicated than it seems.
The second strategy, if you already
know the name of a person or topic,
you can possibly find more
information just based
on that alone.
Third strategy is to find
evidence and verify whether
or not the information that I
found is true, looking for proof.
And lastly, if there's
something that I've discovered,
I try to make a connection between
that information and other points
that might not be apparent
to me at first glance.
Here is an infamous
quote from Aristotle.
This quote emphasizes the
importance of patience.
I say this because the Library of
Congress is not the easiest place
to search and find information.
There are many search engines that
are within the Library of Congress.
And often, documents
have to be found
by utilizing the proper
search method.
And sometimes, that means,
using your own two eyes
to find what you're looking for.
I also like to add, if you're
searching for the term deaf,
you may find multiple hits.
If you search for deaf
mute, the deaf--
the hits that you may
find are different.
Such as deaf and dumb,
another example of something
that may produce different results.
And if you have deaf mute together,
that in it self will
produce different results.
So again, depending on what
combination you use to search,
you can find various results.
Last week in particular, I
searched for the term deaf
and I found 3277 hits online,
however, that's only half.
Here, if you note 7832 hits, so
what that tells you is that you have
to go to the Library of Congress
to find those other hits,
because those results might
be very valuable for the work
that you're trying to complete.
Hopefully, online, the Library
of Congress will have all
those hits available for you.
So, her question or more so
comment was that along with deaf,
a term you can search
is hearing impaired.
As for me, I didn't use
that term in my search
but there are many other terms
as well such as hard of hearing.
Some people might refer
to an individual as hard
of hearing although they
might identify as deaf.
So again, my point here is that
it takes a lot of experimentation
but I have to say that the fruits of
your labor are worth it in the end.
So, going back to my
personal experience,
I searched for the term deaf.
And outside the Library of Congress,
for example, by using google--
-- I use a negative quote.
So, deaf Smith will
actually remove all the hits
that tie into that person.
Sometimes, I can type deaf soldiers,
minus deaf smith or minus deaf to
or minus deaf ears and even deaf ear
without the s. So, there are a lot
of variations that you can
use when you're searching.
However, not every search
engine at the Library
of Congress is capable to do that.
A question?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Instead of a minus
like you do in Google.
>> Harry G. Lang: That's correct.
You can use the not option.
Now, there are many search engines.
And is another example.
Not, like you just
mentioned, is another example.
However, again, I can only
share a few examples here.
Right now, the message that
I'm trying to drive home
to the audience is you really
need to exercise patience
in your research, especially
when you're using the Library
of Congress search engines.
One example I have in mind, if
you go to Alexander Graham Bell
and you search all letters,
I see some of your facial
expressions here not fans
of Alexander Graham Bell, but
nonetheless quite interesting.
When you read the letters
that are pertaining to Bell,
you see a famous deaf
poet, Laura Redden.
And she actually wrote to Bell.
Laura, Laure Redden was a
highly respected figure noted
for all her hard work.
However, most people know
of her after her divorce
from her hearing lawyer, she became
quite financially challenged,
asking for help from friends, and
her story is quite a sad story.
She suffered for many years
of her life financially.
She had a daughter that she
was looking to help raise.
So, in the Bell papers, with the
search results, you can see some
of the correspondence that
took place between Laura
and Alexander Graham Bell.
So, even though Bell has
his own personal attitudes
about sign language, this
individual was still willing
to lend a helping hand and
support Laura by sending her money.
So, sometimes you have to take
things with a grain of salt.
Another interesting comment
I'd like to make, right now,
I'm not sure if you're aware, but
there's a controversy taking place
between Alexander Graham Bell
and his negative comments
about Nyle DiMarco, the dancer.
I do know that Nyle is a
dancer, however, Bell has been--
The Bell Foundation has been very
critical of him, in his support
of early ASL and education
of deaf mute.
So, Bell wrote in the letter
that he actually used
signs with deaf children.
That's something that
we already knew.
And even further, he talks
about the numbers in Arabic
when he was teaching
them to deaf children.
You can find many examples
similar to that
in which he used the sign
language to educate them.
Would you find him on Gallaudet
signing with students on campus?
That's something you can see in
the photographs that are archived.
But again, those Bell letters,
you can't just Google them.
However, you can download
and read them.
Some other letters, for example,
the Abraham Lincoln papers,
you can actually download
the handwritten letters.
If you click on the transcript
option, that's an option
that can be googled easier for any
critical word such as civil war.
So, that's something that
you can find in a letter
that might be important to you.
In the Abraham Lincoln papers, I
decided to search for the term deaf.
I found a letter of a
father who actually wrote
to Abraham Lincoln requesting his
permission to allow him to travel
through the army lines
in order for him
to live closer to his deaf daughter.
And that was in Raleigh, North
Carolina, school for the deaf there.
Abraham Lincoln actually
denied his request.
And my point in that is that
the letter doesn't explain the
whole story.
So, once you find that
piece of information,
you can then do additional research.
You can look for that farther.
All right, in the-- in the
documents on Library of Congress
and in my research I found out
that the father was actually known
to be a spy, so that's the reason
that he was denied the request
to travel through the army lines.
Another example of something you
can download is a PDF document.
Often, PDFs are something that
you can search within the engine.
Although the manuscript might
have been originally handwritten,
you can still search
for that file as a PDF.
I previously mentioned using
transcripts in a prior example.
Referring back to Laura Redden,
she was a very instrumental
woman throughout the civil war.
The curiosity I had was what
relationship did she have
with Abraham Lincoln.
It turned out that she was
actually very good friends
with Abraham Lincoln.
She was also a great acquaintance
with Mary Dodd-- Mary Todd Lincoln,
along with the sons
of Abraham Lincoln.
Laura actually had a copy of
a poem that a young boy wrote.
She gave it to Mary
Todd, and the next day,
the White House actually sent a
huge bouquet of powers to that--
of flowers to that poet
for such an exquisite poem.
So again, these all began with
that brief excerpt that I found
on my original search and
sometimes that requires searching
through the national archives,
Library of Congress, on the web.
If you go to genealogy.com
for example,
you can find evidence
of family papers there.
So there are a number of
ways that you can follow up.
Here is an example of one photograph
out of thousands that showed Edison.
And in this image I found
at the Library of Congress,
I noticed one peculiar
thing about this photograph.
I was wondering to myself,
why did the gentleman
on the left have his finger on the
knee on the gentleman to the right?
Edison was very deaf.
I would assume that he
was almost fully deaf.
He probably had about
70 decibel hearing loss.
It was actually a museum
in my place in Florida
that I've seen a number of times.
He was not skilled when
it came to reading lips.
His hearing was also not great.
Also, sign language was not
something that he was fluent in.
So, how he actually communicated was
through something called Morse code.
He was a very strange man and
he gave a nickname to his nephew
and the nickname was Dash.
And his niece he nicknamed Dot.
So-- He also had other scientists
come visit and have discussions
on his inventions and often
the communication was done
by touching on the knee.
Thomas Edison's girlfriend
before they were married went
to the theaters with him and by
using the index and middle finger,
had a system of communication
that was quite fascinating.
One night, he actually
tapped on his--
This is a true story by the way.
He would tap repeatedly
on his girlfriend's knee
and that was how he proposed to her
and asked if she would marry him,
by this Morse code that they had
utilized, and of course he said yes.
Her question was, did everyone
have to learn Morse code.
My response is only a few people.
Henry Ford would actually
scream in one ear that was--
that he could hear out of better but
that wasn't a great help for Edison.
Most often, people would
use a paper and pencil
to communicate instead
of Morse code.
Another example pertaining
to the Library
of Congress includes
handwritten expert--
excerpt by a gentleman who was
alive during the civil war.
In his story, he referred
to a gentleman by the name
of Freshour I think his last
name was, a deaf individual
who was walking along, and
Union soldiers shouted an order
at him to stop walking.
And because he was deaf, he
didn't hear it and they ended
up shooting him in the
back and killing him.
Other people found out what happened
and then became infuriated
with what happened.
The woman ended up having
to bury this gentleman.
And there are many other
individuals who had points of view
that added on to that story.
So, this excerpt was
quite fascinating.
A heed of warning, sometimes
you have to be careful
because errors may exist.
There are millions and millions
of documents that are coming
in to the Library of Congress.
It's their responsibility to verify
the information that's accurate
and you need to double check that.
I found one nice image here and then
it said it was St. Rica's School
for the Deaf but that
wasn't the correct spelling.
It was actually St.
Rita's School for the Deaf.
So with that said, you have to
double check on the accuracy
and verify information
that you find.
A nice feature that the Library
of Congress has on the website is
that it allows you to submit
corrections to the Library
of Congress, that way they
can make the proper addition--
proper edits and make sure that
the information there is accurate.
Another example of a situation that
requires a little bit of follow-up,
this image has a woman
of-- image of a woman
at the National Association
for the Deaf.
Now, on the Library
of Congress website,
you might not find
the answers to that.
You may use this image there.
I hope Mike Olson still
likes me here.
But he's extremely helpful and
I would recommend that you reach
out to him when it comes
to things like this.
I'm not sure if Gallaudet
has his letters.
Sometimes I have to navigate between
Gallaudet and Library of Congress.
But one thing that I
found interesting is
that Thomas Gallaudet actually wrote
letters to a gentleman in Ohio.
And in those letters, he explained
how it was challenging to set
up a school for the deaf.
There were a lot of complications
that were involved in those efforts,
and it was fascinating to read
those letters and he really wanted
to help this gentleman in Ohio but
his warning was that it's not work
that should be taken lightly.
Setting up a program, curriculum,
those are some of the challenges
that are incorporated with that.
Again, some of that
information I found at Gallaudet,
some of it I found at
the Library of Congress.
Now ultimately, I had to utilize
both sources to get images
of American School for the Deaf
and it was a great way to see
that the evidence of how it
started at that school and then
from American School for the Deaf,
it spread the other
institutions that were built.
So, for the 200th anniversary
of ASD,
I believe some people might
search for images or any evidence
that pertains back to
its original founding.
A question?
>> Hi. I had one more idea
of one source and the Library
of Congress is helping
personally a lot.
If you get stuck, they have the
most wonderful research library use
in the Library of Congress.
They really are a very important
[inaudible] who know so much
to [inaudible] and who have a lot
of energy and a lot of interest
in a different work with them.
So, contact them to--
>> Harry G. Lang: Yes, I certainly
agree with you 100% on that.
No. I did use the librarian's
help personally in trying
to better understand why it was
that I couldn't use negatives
when I was searching in the engine.
For example, you know,
negative Smith in my searches.
But the librarians are
very nice, very friendly.
They responded to my question about
that with several ways to search
on the website differently
than how I have done.
So, that's a great point and you can
certainly follow up and email them
and they're more than
happy to respond to you.
>> Minus sign.
>> Thank you.
>> Harry G. Lang: Another example,
if you know the name of the person
in mind, for example the
French Prince de Joinville.
He was the gentleman I mentioned
this morning who came to America
and met with Abraham Lincoln.
He asked Abraham Lincoln
for permission
to join the Union Army
as role of an adviser.
And he also came to America with
his two French hearing nephews.
Because he was an expert in his
observations, Lincoln assigned him
to the Peninsula campaign
under General McClellan.
You can find a lot of great pictures
of this deaf prince from France
on the Library of Congress website.
I have one picture here and
he is actually the gentleman
with the large cap, and
the second from the right.
When it came to communication, that
was something he struggled with
but he was not alone in that.
I found roughly 10 to
12 various generals
who were significantly
deaf, not profoundly deaf.
I actually call them
pre-enlistment deaf,
which means that they already
had hearing loss before the war.
President Lincoln and the
southern president, Jeff Davis,
needed leaders badly, and
they needed them so badly
that they are able to look
past the fact that some
of these leaders had hearing loss.
Now, some of these leaders did
become more deaf in the war,
and some of those leaders
also died in the war
because they were not able to hear
some of the gunshots and warnings
of their fellow soldiers before
getting killed in the line of war.
This morning, I'll also mention
that the prince had servants.
And pictured here, you
can see those servants.
And I found this at the Library
of Congress and it's interesting,
you can see the servants
who supported prince
and the prince was a great
adviser to Abraham Lincoln.
And again, at the Library
of Congress website,
you can find the letters
that are actually written
from the deaf prince de Joinville
to Abraham Lincoln warning him
of things that he needed to
know regarding some decisions
that Abraham Lincoln were made.
And Abraham Lincoln
was one to take heed
from this deaf prince's
other advisers.
An example-- an example
is the Trent Affair.
So when the Union Army
captured sailboats,
they were carrying two
southern officers to England.
So, they captured them and
imprisoned them but the waters
that the boat was on was
considered international waters.
So, the prince gave
a warning about that
that you are violating
international rule.
So, because of that warning,
Abraham Lincoln dismissed
these two gentlemen.
There are many drawings that
were found, many arts of work.
One example here is
of the deaf prince.
When the ships that were sunk
in the battle of the Ironclads,
which is a very well known battle,
there was actually a hearing artist
who was drawing him
at the same time.
So, the artist, Waud, was a hearing
artist who is drawing a portrait
of the deaf prince as the deaf
prince was drawing a portrait
of the boat that had sunk.
I mentioned previously that some
of the generals had some
pretty serious hearing loss.
Maxcy Pregg--
>> Gregg.
>> Harry G. Lang: -- or Maxcy
Gregg, a southern general was killed
in the Fredericksburg battle.
And the reason for that was
because he didn't hear his own
soldier's warning that the enemy,
the Union enemy was approaching.
And the other officers
said that the reason
for his death was because
he was deaf.
I didn't realize that
right before the war,
Maxcy Gregg was actually
very involved
with the South Carolina secession,
specifically from the Union.
So, some stories that you're
writing have deeper connections
than you might realize
at first glance.
Many of you might be aware that
Abraham Lincoln was actually
in the middle of the war.
Not only was he in
the middle of the war
but he read a full book of poems.
He was very encapsulated by poems.
And these were the days of war
where there was no security
around the White House, and
someone can simply just walk
in to the White House and hand
the president poems for him
to read, and that happened.
Did he really read
some of those poems?
Well, there's a quote that he
said the poems are very pretty,
particularly the ones that
are related to the war,
so I was looking for
evidence of that.
In the Library of Congress there's
a letter from Laura writing--
thanking Abraham Lincoln
for his support in her book
and you can actually see
the original writing here
in that letter.
She says thank you
for endorsing my book.
Here's another example.
So I might be wondering, you
know, did Edward Miner Gallaudet,
I believe this is the correct sign.
Some might be wondering, did Edward
Miner Gallaudet really write a
letter of invitation
to the president?
Well, here on the screen
you can see that's true.
And also I believe the
Gallaudet archives has a copy
of this invitation extended
to the president on behalf
of Edward Miner Gallaudet.
So, by using the Library
of Congress search engine,
I was able to verify this.
Now, the fourth strategy that
I used was making connections
for the deaf prince
that I was referring to.
He actually wrote a letter
to a Massachusetts politician
and in this letter, the deaf prince
expressed that he was very impressed
with a young man that
he had met who happened
to be the famous General Custer.
Now, I wasn't even aware that
myself that they knew each other.
And one has to wonder
how they communicated.
I'm sure that the prince did know a
lot of sign language but Custer did.
And the reason for that was because
he visited a school for the deaf
in Texas and there he went
to encounter deaf children.
Also, Custer's wife wrote a
book talking about his journey
to the school for the deaf where
he encountered those deaf children.
And also communication with Native
Americans was done by signing.
Here's another example
of making connection.
Are you aware that the Library
of Congress has more
than five million maps?
Five million.
So with that said, I was looking for
the term deaf in any of the maps,
and an option you have are selecting
based on letters, photographs, maps,
drawings, and from
that-- from those options,
you can select what you want.
So, in my mind I thought I'd search
for deaf as it related to maps
and this is something I found.
In the left top corner here, I
just happen to spot something.
There's a picture of the North
Carolina School for the Deaf,
and I wondered why would
that be on the map, right,
in the top left corner there.
And it just so happened
that a person by the name
of Cooke was the principal and
he moved there from Virginia
and he became the president
at that school in Raleigh
and be brought equipment to
print at that school with him
and ultimately went on
to set up a print shop
for young boys to learn
how to print.
So, from the name Cooke, I was
able to make that connection.
I saw the deaf school on
the map and I realized
that Cooke ultimately
helped the deaf children
to become very proficient
in publication and printing.
So when the war began,
all the confederate money
was actually printed there,
and bullets were also something
that the children made there.
But more importantly, there were
training manuals for soldiers.
So what that told me was that
this particular deaf school
on North Carolina was very
supportive of the Confederate Army.
Here is an enlarged image
of the school for the deaf
that was in the top left corner.
I'm curious, how many of
you here are from Maryland.
Show of hands.
Are you familiar with the
song "Maryland, My Maryland"?
>> It's still the state song.
>> Harry G. Lang: Is it
still the state song?
I heard that it was very
controversial, and there were talks
that they might drop this song.
"Maryland, My Maryland"
actually has the word deaf
but it's not related to deaf people.
So, referring to Maryland,
all right,
she is not deaf, nor dead, nor dumb.
Huzza! she spurns the northern scum.
So I think this song is
actually still used today.
And first, I'd like to
mention, well, for some of you,
this might be insignificant,
the fact that they mentioned
deaf and dumb is very broad.
And it's not referring
to what they called--
what they called people at the time.
But if you know enough, you
can actually make a connection.
Because based on the same
Library of Congress website,
you can actually find another song.
In Belle Missouri, their
fighting song, their fighting song
for the Missouri soldiers were
actually written by Laura Redden.
So she was the deaf woman who was
actually invited to write that song
in response to "Maryland,
My Maryland".
So here we have a deaf
woman who was invited
to make a response
to the Maryland song.
Both of those songs
are part of the history
and my point here is it's
interesting how you can make
connections between those findings.
Now before you read this, I believe
I have two slides left before I wrap
up here.
If you recalled in the
beginning of my presentation,
I said that I was an
educator for 41 years.
And I also said that in
my heart, I have a desire
to inspire deaf children.
There was an occasion where
I was giving a presentation,
and afterwards the Library
of Congress is where I went
to find information about
deaf scientists as well
as engineers among other
things that I found on the web.
My presentation was given to deaf
children in schools for the deaf
and I recall parents along
with other professionals
who were present.
There was one mother who
actually wrote this letter to me
and from this letter, I was
actually moved to tears.
Clarification, in the letter it was
stated that the mother was moved
to tears as she listened to Dr.
Lang's tell of the gifts given to us
by our deaf predecessors
with admiration and respect.
From my presentation, this
woman felt far more confident
that her son could excel
and succeed in science,
and that to me was worth
writing the whole damn book.
Another story related to science,
about women and men science,
I can think of actually happened
with a young woman in Pittsburg.
This young woman applied
for a master's degree.
Well, she applied to get
into a master's program.
She already had her bachelor's
in biology and she wanted
to get a master's in neuroscience.
And I actually have permission
from her to share the story.
The University of Pittsburg
at the time said that science
for a deaf woman wouldn't be a
good fit, and they turned her
down in her application
to join the program.
Now, she went to see a counselor
and this counselor actually knew me
because it was counselor at Western
Pennsylvania School for the Deaf
in Pittsburg where I graduated.
And the first book I actually
wrote and he gave her this copy,
and this copy of what
I wrote referred
to a woman, a deaf woman in science.
So that led-- that led this deaf
woman to go back to the University
of Pittsburg with this book,
and after they read it,
they had changed their mind.
Afterwards, they accepted her.
After accepting her into the
program, she completed her master's
in neuroscience, went
on to pursue her PhD.
And one nice thing about this young
deaf woman was that she asked me
to be a part of her dissertation.
So, from my book, I
found that the people
who I influenced ranged
from young and old.
And at the Library of Congress you
can find those kinds of information.
>> I was actually wondering
where can I have access
to that book you mentioned
in your previous slide,
or that quote in your previous
slide, where can I find that?
>> Harry G. Lang: I can't recall the
gentleman's name, but this gentleman
who helped me out with
the slides and he told me
that all my slides will be
accessible on the Library
of Congress website, so you
can pull it out from there.
>> I would like a copy of this.
>> Can you go back to the previous--
>> Could you-- Could--
>> Harry G. Lang: When you
actually pull it up on the website,
you can download that letter.
Or if you like, you can
email me afterwards.
I have the copyright.
[ Laughter ]
>> Well, I guess, I'm sorry but I
interrupted you to ask [inaudible].
>> Harry G. Lang: Well, in
summary, there's a ton of rich,
wonderful information at
the Library of Congress.
And also, the Library of
Congress is very supportive
of people with other disabilities.
Thirdly, understanding deafness as
not only the educational aspect,
but the cultural history
is helpful as well.
And lastly, I highly commend
the Library of Congress
in the National Literacy--
>> Literary--
>> Harry G. Lang: Literary
Society for the Deaf
in promoting the reading and
writing in deaf education,
and ultimately I found
that in my research.
Thank you so much for inviting
me here to speak today.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: That was a wonderful
presentation, the second one.
Thank you, Harry.
[ Applause ]
Before we move on, I have a--
one very brief Library of
Congress Abraham Lincoln story.
Many of you know that the Library
of Congress is the first
presidential library.
Before the FDR, Franklin Delano
Roosevelt started his library,
all of the presidential
papers came here
and they came here
including for Abraham Lincoln.
And when my boss, Mr. Boorstin,
became Librarian of Congress
in 1975, he went in the closet
in the librarian's office
in the old building and he
said there was a package
that said the contents of
Lincoln's pockets the night he
was assassinated.
And we didn't understand what that
could be or if it were even true
because the Lincoln papers of course
had come earlier in the century
from Robert Lincoln who was his son.
But it turned out that the family
hung on to indeed a package
that had the contents of his
pockets and that was placed
in the librarian's office.
And Dr. Boorstin was the
Librarian of Congress
and so he rapidly opened it up
and it contained indeed
Lincoln's wallet, his eyeglasses.
And in his wallet, it was filled
with clippings about himself,
but also confederate
money was in his pockets.
And Dr. Boorstin immediately put
this on display but it turned
out the family, it was
part of the initial gift
but the family had held it
back and it came in the 1930s
and no one knows why the Librarian
of Congress didn't open the package.
But maybe he was just
respecting the Lincoln family.
So there's a little bit of
mystery related to the relationship
between Lincoln and the
Library of Congress,
but it's been a strong
historical relationship.
And Harry has gone ahead and added
to that a great deal I
think this afternoon.
Our next speaker, Alice of--
Hagemeyer is going to talk about
deaf cultures and American parents.
And do you have-- Is Noah
Beckman here to help you, Alice?
Oh, there you are.
Thank you.
And let me have the two of you
come up and take another look
at our general discussion,
but this time it's
from quite a different perspective.
So I will turn the stage
over to Alice and to Noah.
Deaf cultures, American parents.
And I've also noticed
that from now on,
we are in our presentations going
to actually feature a number
of personalities who
have been important
in the history of deaf culture.
And I look forward to your
presentation very much.
Thank you.
>> And we'll have Ricardo
Lopez come up in a bit as well.
>> Noah Beckman: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I am thrilled to be here.
And before we get started, go
ahead and interrupt me at any point
if you feel like you've
missed something or you want
to clarify something that I've said.
Before we really get started,
there are some different
parts to our program.
Alice Hagemeyer will
talk for a portion of it
and then she'll hand it off to me
and then Wesley Arey
will also be speaking,
and then we'll have Ricardo
facilitating the FAQs at the end.
So I believe we have a
really exciting program.
Alice, would you like
to introduce yourself?
For the first part
of our presentation, we
have Alice Hagemeyer.
And you may know her as the
founder of the Red Book,
that became FOLDA,
that is now the NLSD.
And she can explain that
a little bit further.
It is my honor to introduce
her, so please,
welcome Alice Hagemeyer
to the floor.
[ Applause ]
The slides will be advanced for you.
You simply just have
to let them know.
>> Alice L. Hagemeyer: That's good.
I'm not so good with
technology myself.
Hello everyone.
My topic today is deaf
cultures and American parents.
So you've seen different themes come
through during the
presentations of today.
And we've talked quite a
bit about deaf culture,
which includes lifestyles
and behaviors
and perspectives and so forth.
So we often refer to
this as deaf culture.
Rather than saying deaf and
hard of hearing community
or the deaf community,
we really do want
to emphasize the cultural
aspect this afternoon.
If you can advance the slide.
>> Noah Beckman: We have someone
taking care of that for you.
So you just simply have
to kind of look their way.
You see, you see him
waiving right there?
That's the person responsible
for advancing the slides.
So as soon as you give them the
cue, they will advance it for you.
>> Alice L. Hagemeyer: Very good.
Thank you.
Of course, one size of
services doesn't fit all.
So we've developed a
variety of guidelines
for better serving our deaf culture.
When I first joined the
American Library Association,
this was when they were
celebrating their 100th anniversary.
That was 1976.
At that time, there were
no specified services
for the deaf community.
They had services for
the blind and the serve--
and services for physically
handicapped,
but there was no mention of
services for deaf people.
So I was involved in
setting up those services.
We discussed what they
should be called
because this was a very
new concept for librarians
who for the most part
hadn't met deaf people.
There were people who were
hard of hearing involved
in the Library Association
who didn't really identify
with deaf culture.
And so this whole concept
of deaf culture was very new
to the Librarian Association.
And just went to call those services
led to quite a bit of discussion.
Today we just say deaf and
hard of hearing to refer
to the deaf services
provided the libraries.
Now the members of the American
Library Association wanted
to make it easier for Library
of Congress and public libraries
to serve the deaf community.
They realized the gap existed.
And we decided at that time to just
refer to these services as deaf,
because we see that
as a positive term.
And it is an umbrella term
that encompasses all sorts
of healing loss and deaf identities.
So, hearing children with
deaf parents can identify
with this term deaf when
we refer to deaf services.
So it's a very broad term.
Now the reason why the American
Library Association established
these services was, as I
said, to make the job easier
for all libraries, not just Library
of Congress but all libraries
to serve the deaf community.
So as Harry Lang was saying with
his research that he's done,
that's there because of
the work of the libraries
to get these resources in place.
And so as I said earlier,
we're talking this afternoon
about deaf cultures and within
the American Library Association,
there is a group that's
called Bridging Deaf Cultures
at your library.
And that's led by Alec McFarlane.
He is not a librarian but is
certainly a friend of libraries.
And so we've worked quite
closely on this program
to make the jobs easier, the work
easier for librarians to connect
with their deaf communities.
I-- remember this is a workshop
format, so I want to make sure
that at any time you have question
that you feel free to ask them.
>> OK, if we could
advance to next slide.
>> Alice L. Hagemeyer: This morning
we had various speakers talking
about different topics, all
of them of course related
to deaf or hard of hearing.
And you might wonder about the
differences between these terms.
When I joined American
Library Association,
the word library was not
seen as in positive terms.
They wanted it to be
library and information.
A similar process happened
within the deaf community.
There's deaf, there's hard of
hearing, what terms do we embrace.
And again, we decided upon the
term deaf to include all of us.
But you might remember
a time-- I'm sorry.
You of course might have
personal experience with people
who call themselves deaf
because of hearing loss related
to aging or variety of reasons.
And so it's become a word that
has become positive in nature.
It can include, as I said as an
umbrella term, it include children
with deaf parents, people
who are hard of hearing.
And this morning we talked
about children and the right
to access a language
that's accessible to them.
We're all working together
within this community
because we have common goals.
Is there a question?
>> Noah Beckman: I am not great
at mirroring those questions
and repeating them, so I'll
just have an interpreter step
on stage for you.
>> And you do the questions
and I'll do that [inaudible].
>> Yeah.
>> Hi, Alice.
I would like to add some input.
I think there are some good
examples of that, of the dialogue
that happens between Art
Roehrig about those types
of discussions and those additions.
So I would say that you should
have a conversation with Art.
He is one of my old friends,
and I would like to ask
where your recognition is of those
individuals who are deaf-blind.
We were in Cleveland
recently just for a visit.
We were visiting some
old friends of ours.
Chuck Williams, who is
very well known in the--
as a black death advocate.
He is on the board at
Gallaudet University
and we were having a conversation
with him while we were there,
and it just so happened
that another friend
of ours had gone to the library.
They're in Cleveland and had
found your book and was surprised
that his name was actually
in the book.
And his visual arts name was in
the book and he was described
as vision impaired
when he identifies--
When you say you're using
the word deaf but adding all
of those other identifying
terms is not as acceptable.
So it's just something that I
wanted to call to your attention.
>> Alice L. Hagemeyer:
This is a good point.
I have spoken with some deaf-blind
friends and they have felt much
like second class citizens, like a
subcategory in the deaf community
and we certainly don't
want that to be the case.
There are deaf people with
intellectual disabilities,
physical disabilities, et cetera,
and what we want to see is one term
that encompasses it--
the entire community
so that we can best provide
services to this group
as an entire community
even though it is diverse.
So we established the deaf--
the Deaf Culture Digital Library
which describes many of
our services that we offer,
and it's used by a lot
of people doing research.
It helps them save on time when
they're working on their projects.
So again, this is a term that
encompasses the entire community.
Did somebody else have a question?
>> So, if Thomas had become deaf
later in life but still identified
as hearing, that aspect
of it is lost.
There are people with hearing loss
and maybe not a profound hearing
loss, but do we still identify them
as deaf or could they
identify as hard of hearing?
>> Alice L. Hagemeyer:
The rules that we follow
with our library services is not
to consider this a disability.
We look at people first concepts.
We look at our customers as people.
So when a person enters a library,
they don't have to check the box,
are they deaf or hard
of hearing, deaf-blind.
We respect all people equally
with the programs that we serve.
Now, a person who becomes deaf
later in life we hope will be able
to accept that fact as part of their
life, and we have storytellings,
a variety of programs that draw
in that particular audience,
people who were deafened
later in life.
So, the idea is not to consider
hearing loss but deaf gain.
This is a new term
that's come on the scene.
I had a cousin I haven't seen for
many years, we grew up together,
and this person never
really saw me as an equal.
It was a common perspective
on me as a deaf person.
And my cousin said they are
now, as an older person,
experiencing hearing loss and
that they don't have enough money
to buy hearing aids.
And so, I was trying to help
them understand that instead
of seeing this is a process of
loss, it's a process of gain
that you're adding to your identity.
And so, they have so many
anecdotal stories like this
about people trying to
adjust to that change
and then coming to embrace it.
Now, we do want to talk
about parents as part
of deaf culture in America.
And Noah is going to share with
us a story of one hearing parent
of a deaf child from our history.
And we prepared this because it's
a story that's been told throughout
our history in libraries
and elsewhere.
It's the story of a hearing
man with a deaf daughter.
This was Maxwell Fitch
Cogswell-- Mason Fitch Cogswell.
His daughter, Alice,
you may know was famous
at the American School for the Deaf.
And this is a story that has
become part of our heritage and one
that Noah is going to share
with us as an example of stories
that can be told at any public
library to help spread the message
of the deaf community
and deaf culture.
>> Noah Beckman: Thank you.
You could advance, yup, perfect.
This seems to be a better place
to stand behind the podium.
Mason Fitch Cogswell, which I will
abbreviate MFC so I won't have
to fingerspell his name every time.
I actually got the content
from Alice's readings,
it's actually really quite
fascinating and I'm happy
to share that story with you.
Hopefully, it'll be a
learning moment for you.
I am not a historian.
I'm a librarian at Gallaudet
and became fascinated with this.
So, if you could show
the picture please.
I don't know, do we
look similar maybe?
[ Laughter ]
This is an example of what
he look like, no mustache
but a nice beard and
very well dressed.
He's got his spectacles on there.
So, this is Mason Fitch Cogswell.
And this year, we could
celebrate his 255th birthday
if he were still living.
Being 255 years old,
that's something
to keep in mind for this story.
He was born in the fall
of 1771 in Connecticut
in a town called Cadbury.
He was born in 1772.
His mother did pass not
long after he was born.
He was survived by
his-- with his father,
John Cogswell and he was a pastor.
And he was offered a position
at a church in Scotland.
But he had a young son.
At that time, he had Mason and
so he got in touch with someone
who was rather famous at
the time, Samuel Hutchinson,
who was a delegate in the congress
when he was in Philadelphia.
He ran the Continental Congress
and he had also signed the
Declaration of Independence.
He is one of many signatures
on the declaration.
And so, he was a very
reputable person at that time.
And so, he brought Mason Fitch
Cogswell under his tutelage.
And he was a very brilliant man.
He got accepted into
Yale and was one
of the brightest scholars at Yale.
He finished his studies at 19 years
old, me finishing my studies at 23.
He was the valedictorian
of his class.
He chose to study medicine.
And Mason Fitch Cogswell
had an older brother,
also named James Cogswell, who
was a physician in New York City
and he was a physician during the
time of the American Revolution.
And so, he worked and studied
under his older brother
so that he could get more
experience in the medical field
and would be ready to be
able to practice on his own.
When deciding where to
live, he decided to go back
to Connecticut and
rode there by horse.
And when he got to his hometown,
he became very overwhelmed
by his memories of Connecticut
and being at Yale, and he decided
to actually move to Hartford,
Connecticut and settle.
There were too many memories
and friends in his hometown.
As a physician, he
grew quite famous.
He was recognized for
two great acts.
He removed a cataract-- and if
you give me just one second.
Yes, he was able to
remove a cataract off
of an eye before the
actual cataract broke.
He removed it in one piece.
He was also very famous for-- what?
>> Tying off the carotid artery.
>> Noah Beckman: Tying
off the carotid artery.
And he was the first one
to do that successfully.
So, he was a very well-renowned
physician at that time.
He became famous due to
those two large feats.
Give me one second to
find my notes here.
The State of Connecticut, the
Medical Society, the individual
who ran that at that
time studied under him.
He had many people
under his tutelage
that became doctors in Connecticut.
They offered him the head of
a medical school position.
He decided to decline that
offer because he wanted to stay
in Hartford, Connecticut.
And you can see his contributions.
He founded the school--
or founded a residence--
residential school
for mental health.
And I just checked last week
and it's actually still running.
And so, that's a contribution that
he was able to give to the community
that is still functioning today.
He ultimately married and had
a family and had some children
and Alice was the third
of those children.
She was identified as deaf
and they wanted to try,
obviously as a physician,
to fix her hearing.
And so, while socializing with
friends, they saw an article
from the Braidwood School that
they had successfully educated
deaf children.
And there was a school in Virginia
but it was a residential school
and it was only a temporary
school at that time.
They knew Thomas Hopkins Gallaudet.
He had known him from-- Mason
had known him from Yale and being
in the community together.
And so, they got to talking.
And remember at that time,
Mason Fitch Cogswell
was very well connected.
He had several lawyer buddies.
He was connected and
affiliated with congressmen.
He was able to easily
raise the money
to send Thomas Hopkins Gallaudet to
London to see the Braidwood School
and ultimately get
their teaching methods.
Give me just one second.
And because of all of
these interaction, it was--
ultimately, the first school
for the deaf was founded
in the United States.
So, we want to thank
Mason Fitch Cogswell
for him planting the initial
seed that created education
for deaf individuals
in the United States.
Schools ultimately were
founded from the American School
for the Deaf's graduates.
They went on to open their
school and this was in 1817.
He passed away in 1830.
And Alice was very close with
Mason Fitch Cogswell, her father,
and was very proud of the
work that he had done,
they had developed a
very strong connection.
And once her father
passed, she was very upset.
She actually passed 13 days after
him, at the young age of 25.
So now, I want to take the
opportunity to commemorate
and celebrate Mason Fitch Cogswell
for his contributions and the work
that he's done for
the deaf community.
He is an American parent
of a deaf child.
We're very proud of him.
Thank you.
>> Alice L. Hagemeyer:
Thank you Noah.
And if you would like access
to this story, please join LDS.
And then you'll see examples
of stories just like this
that you can use in your
own research efforts
and to help spread the word to
your libraries and your communities
about stories in our
history like this.
We have these services
in all 50 states plus DC
and the US territories.
Thank you.
And let me check if Wesley is ready.
Are there any other
questions at this point?
How many of you know
who this person is?
Laurent Clerc?
You know, many of the younger
generation don't know who Clerc is
which is really a travesty.
That falls on the job--
the job falls on people
like yourself and me.
We need to keep on
teaching deaf history.
We can't forget people in our
heritage like Laurent Clerc.
He, Cogswell, Thomas
Hopkins Gallaudet,
together founded the first
school for the deaf in America.
It was the first school
on the western hemisphere,
first public school for deaf people.
And this year, we recognize
the 200th anniversary of Clerc
and Gallaudet's arrival, their trip
from France to found this school.
So we commemorate that
200th anniversary.
And next year, the school AST will
be having their own celebrations
to commemorate their
200th anniversary.
So now, we'll call up Wesley Arey.
Make sure I've got his name right
because this is only the
first time I've met him.
>> Wesley Arey: This is the first
time I've actually stand on a stage
with a podium so please forgive me
as I'm learning how
get through this.
I'm a little bit awkward.
I'm not quite a pro but
I'll give it a shot.
My actual name is Wesley Arey.
But in the story, I will take
the character of Laurent Clerc.
I'll try to make this very clear and
I'm going to have to put my glasses
on here because my vision
is getting worse as I age.
So, bear with me.
[ Laughter ]
You know, actually, if
I put my glasses on,
I have a hard time
seeing the audience.
So, I'll leave the glasses off.
I'm going to try my best here.
Laurent Clerc.
This is in sign so I'm
taking on my character now.
On Tuesday, June 18th 1816,
Laurent Clerc is traveling
to America with Gallaudet.
The name of the ship
is Mary Augusta.
It's a rather small ship.
As we enter the boat you see six
individuals, two of which are French
and four of which are American.
One of the French men
seems to be unhappy.
And the reason is well,
there's no communication
and this person doesn't know English
so, he's out of conversation then.
All passports are checked
to make sure
that they can go on their voyage.
Here, we see the deck on the ship.
And inside the ship we have a
cabin where daily prayers was held.
We have our routine there in the
morning, afternoon and the evening.
Upon standing on the deck you
see the glorious ocean there.
And afterwards go back down
to the cabin, do some reading,
go back to the daily routine.
All in all, the trip
took about 52 days.
Laurent Clerc, a French gentlemen
looking at Gallaudet, an American,
language, culture was exchanged.
So I learned English
being a Frenchmen knowing
that I have quite a
long journey ahead of me
and I'm not fluent in English.
So, as I'm being taught,
I also teach.
Before eating, of course,
washing of the hands,
making sure that you're well
groomed, appear to be taken care of,
prayer, tea, nightly
readings and an array of food
as well as water and wine.
Again, knowing no English,
I'll try my best
to learn English language asking
Thomas get question after question.
One month into the voyage.
I noticed that fluency in the
language is picking up quite fast.
Almost as fast as the
ship is traveling
And this exchange of language
and culture takes place
everyday on this journey.
On the ship, while the gentlemen are
exchanging stories, a man is spotted
on the shroud of the ship.
Captain, a gentlemen on
the shroud is prohibited.
A letter is given to the
captain and the captain laughs
because in is his mind, being
on the shroud isn't prohibited.
Clerc responds, on the ship that
I boarded, it was prohibited to be
on the shroud when I was
traveling from France to England.
It appears that you allow
that, quite different.
Friday, June 21st.
Looking back at how far I've come,
picking up this English language,
riding back and forth in
English day in and day out.
There's nothing else to do aside
from observe the waves
crashing as I'm aboard the ship.
June 22nd.
Gallaudet explains
the American culture.
So, that's what American
culture is like, I say to myself.
Every Sunday, we respect the
tradition of the Sabbath.
And every Sunday, there
would be sermons
and those sermons will be
preached to the crew on the ship.
And me being deaf, I
wasn't able to hear that.
So, written sermon is
given to me instead.
I look at the dictionary
doing my best
to follow what everyone
else is following.
Treacherous waters
calmed by the sermon.
Prayer, serenity.
The next night, bouts of
sea sickness, not for me
but for others I observe on
the ship, including Gallaudet.
As someone who frequents the ship,
sea sickness doesn't affect me
but I'm not able to sleep
with the ship rocking back
and forth, I lie restless.
Finally, in the early hour
of five in the morning,
I'm able to fall sleep and
shortly after, I'm woken up.
Painfully, I get up out the bed.
Going to eat breakfast,
morning prayer,
stand on the deck and observe.
I recall Gallaudet mentioning
Alice Cogswell and his desire
for all of us to meet together.
It just so happened
that once upon a time,
we actually had crossed paths
and I wasn't even aware.
Conversations with the crew ensue,
letters written back and forth.
Is my wife deaf and dumb, I'm asked.
And my response, of course,
we share the same suffering.
We share the same challenges.
June 27th.
Another day of entries on
my battery and I'm shocked
to see crews screaming,
there's a monster
in the ocean, monster in the ocean.
After looking in the
ocean and seeing nothing,
I thought to myself,
perhaps it was a whale.
I recall Gallaudet continuing
to help my English skills,
helping me with my writing.
I recall being praised
for my ability to pick
up the English language
by Gallaudet.
All this time we're on the
ocean, I'm doing my best.
Other members on the crew realizing
that I've made some progress
and they make comments about that.
Throughout our voyage, Gallaudet and
I are talking about ideas on setting
up a school for the deaf.
What should we do?
What's the best way to go about it?
What would be the age of these
students at the school for the deaf?
Often, parents don't want to let go
of their kids at such a young age.
That's something we
had to think about.
How long will they be in school?
Another consideration.
Perhaps, for those who are coming
from wealthy families,
they'll stay longer.
June 30th.
I recall the design of the ship
with a gentleman standing there
and just barely gets missed by
a part on the ship that falls
from the shroud, just
barely missing him.
Duck, chicken, pig,
canary, the canary was not
for eating, don't be fooled.
It was only for song purposes, to
listen to the joys of the music.
I recall a hog and
slaughtered, coming nauseous,
avoiding the deck what-- with
all the blood being spilled.
Quiet a traumatizing experience.
Perhaps an experience best withheld.
[ Laughter ]
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Six hundred miles away,
600 nautical miles.
So, does that mean, it'll
take 90 days to seashore?
With the wind picking up, it gave
us hope to take less than 90 days.
July 2nd. Now, it's
our second month.
On July 3rd, going about my
normal routine in the morning,
brushing my teeth,
I'm shocked to get hit
with such a strong gust of wind.
A gust so strong it knocks
the glass out of my hand
and shatters on the
deck of the ship.
Alas, the 4th of July, celebrations,
discussions about pride
of your country over glasses of
wine leading to a great night sleep.
July 6th. Again, a restless night
uncomfortable quarters of the cabin.
Torrential weather, a fog, unable
to see, of course, making me think
to sleep and rest while
we travel through that.
July 10th, we've run out of papers.
How can we communicate?
Luckily, we have a clean
slate at our disposal.
A slate for us to communicate
back and forth.
An odd silence upon the ship,
so silent the hearing crew
on the ship could even
hear a cat eating a mouse.
Similar to the ducks that
were eating the mouse.
And because the crew found out
that ducks were eating the mice,
they no longer wanted to continue
eating the duck because they felt,
in turn, they were
eating the mice as well.
July 11th.
With the canary in the cage day
after day finally, it's
freed out the cage.
And because it's been confined
to this cage for so long,
its bearings have been lost.
It stumbles off the
deck into the ocean.
A life boat is lowered
of the side of the ship
to rescue this revered duck.
And lo and behold a
turtle in the ocean,
for eating purposes of course.
Again, a terrible fog.
And the ship is carefully
navigating us to not hit anything
that might be in the ocean.
And at last, on August
6th, the fog passes.
And before us, we're looking at
the coast of Boston, Massachusetts.
On August 8th, we see
the shores of New York.
Thanks to good weather
we've made it safely.
The end.
[ Applause ]
And I apologize that I had
to look back to my notes
as I didn't have the whole
story memorized, but thank you.
>> Alice L. Hagemeyer: Do you know
where he got that information from?
From Clerc's letters that he wrote.
And so, you can tell that that
story comes from the heart.
And if you want access to that
story, please sign your name up on
to the e-mail list
and I'll make sure
that I can get you more information.
Not only stories about
Clerc but other stories
that you can tell in
your home areas.
So, thank you so much.
>> Wesley Arey: Thank you
for inviting me to come here.
It's been an honor.
I appreciate it.
>> Alice L. Hagemeyer: We
are proud to have you here
and I think that's
your first time here
in the Library of Congress, right?
>> Wesley Arey: Yes.
And I would also like
to deeply thank you
for making a first
blog in the history.
Now, she knows how to make
a video log, imagine that.
>> Alice L. Hagemeyer:
Oh, thank you.
Thank you so much.
I'm happy to have you here with us.
I think that that's it.
Pardon me.
The next portion of our
workshop is the FAQs,
the frequently asked questions.
And I'm going to ask
that Ricardo Lopez come
up to moderate those questions.
We're happy to answer
anything that comes to mind.
>> Ricardo Lopez: Hello.
Hello everyone.
Again, it's been great
watching Wesley tell that story.
Many years, he was president of
NLSD, and that's exactly what I mean
by that, being able to
pass down that legacy.
And we bring legacy forward related
to deaf culture via story telling.
And so, that's how we preserve
our legacy, we pass it forward.
So, I hope you enjoyed his story.
There are many, many different
ways you can express your legacy.
Sometimes, it's funny.
Sometimes, it's serious.
It depends on your own
individual preference.
But that's exactly what we're about.
I was just informed that there
is a small change to the plan.
We're going to take a
limited number of questions
because are very limited
related to time.
So, I'll take about
two or three questions
and then we'll need
to wrap things up.
And I would invite you to-- if
you have any other questions be it
to the NLSD or anyone else,
anything that you want to know,
any burning questions
that you really need
to get off your chest,
now is the opportunity.
And so, we have an interpreter to
copy sign the questions on stage.
>> Well, I actually wanted
to acknowledge Wesley Arey.
>> Sit down.
>> I would like to
acknowledge his work
because I think it's been my
dream to have a story told
about the journey that took
place, the voyage from France
to America loud and
clear, Thomas Gallaudet.
The exchange of culture, language,
all those important
things that took place.
And I'm really looking for someone
who can write some of those stories
and disseminate that,
because ultimately,
I think that it would be ideal
to make a movie from that.
So, for your great work Wesley,
I would like to thank you.
>> Wesley Arey: Right.
I think that that's a great
idea, potentially filming a movie
to preserve deaf history.
And so, there's the beginning
of an idea right there.
Any other questions?
No? Any burning questions you
want to get off your chest?
Yes.
>> I work at an academic library
here in DC and we don't have a lot
of deaf students [inaudible]
deaf students in DC tend--
they tend to go to Gallaudet
but, I wonder if there's--
if you have ideas for how we
can help with the preservation
of deaf culture in a community
where-- that's mostly hearing.
>> Wesley Arey: I think that
that's a great question for Noah.
>> Noah Beckman: OK.
I do think that that is a
great question and I work
at Gallaudet University
as a librarian.
And just as an example, we
celebrated women's history month.
And so, we included the
aspect of deaf women.
Next year, we're going to
plan on having an exhibit.
We're going to have films by
deaf individuals and we're going
to invite students to
come and watch that.
In terms of service, I think
that things are mostly
communication related.
You need someone who is
comfortable communicating
with the deaf community.
And for deaf students,
their research is not
always specifically related
to deaf culture, any
academic field of study,
any service like that would also
be a benefit to the deaf community.
So, the cultural awareness
aspect, the identity,
there are some things
that you can try.
But even at Gallaudet,
we're still kind
of working our way
through those waters.
And I think that that's the
best answer that I can give you
for now is to really focus on the
accessibility communication aspect.
>> Wesley Arey: And if you're
talking about program activities
for the library, perhaps you can
reach out to Noah or someone else
who works in the library
for more specific ideas.
>> They already have a school
in DC that works specifically
with DC public libraries,
Janice, get in touch with her.
It's DC public schools
and that's affiliated
with the deaf library services so
that can be an in as well for you.
>> Wesley Arey: And you work in DC?
>> I work at George-- at GW
University, at the library there.
>> Wesley Arey: OK.
>> I have an idea, GW is very
close, why not invite lecturers
from Gallaudet University or the
library itself to come and sign
and lecture or a panel
or a group discussion.
That's it.
>> Wesley Arey: The power
of networking, right?
Are there any other final questions?
Maybe one more?
OK. Seeing none, I want
to thank you for coming.
I want to thank you
for your attention.
We have Travis up to make
a final presentation.
>> Travis Painter: Hello everyone,
this will be the last
presentation today.
And today, I'm going to talk
about bridging culture
with the library here.
So, how do we bridge culture?
Internships.
So, here at the Library of Congress,
we have different kind
of internships.
So, if you look at the employment
climate right now, and you see a lot
of competition but
you'll also notice
that employers really
desire experience.
But, if you've never had a job,
how will you get experience?
So, there's this paradox of trying
to figure out how to make this work
and we've done that by
creating internships.
So, it seems, once
people graduate college,
they're ready to start a career and
get on with their life but they kind
of have to take a few steps back
to take an internship in order
to develop their work skills.
So here at the Library of
Congress, in the year 2000,
we developed a program, MIP,
the Model Internship Program.
That consisted of 17
deaf students from MSSD.
And all together, their work
hours ended up being about 4500.
So-- And that was within one year.
So, in that one year, they were
able to contribute to the goals
of the library through
their internships.
And they worked in
different divisions,
they worked in Germanic
and Slavic [inaudible].
They worked in copyright as well.
And so, they got to
have an experience
in all these different
divisions within the library.
And also, there's a nice
quote at the bottom.
So, that was our experience
with internships in the past.
And right now, we actually have
developed a new internship program
within ISP, which is the
Interpreting Services Program here
at the library.
So, what we have done
is we have taken
in one student, her
name is Mekaella.
And if you listen to
the voice right now,
that is actually Mekaella
interpreting for me.
And she's our intern.
And she's actually
the first ISP intern
that we've had here at the library.
So, we're kind of developing a pilot
to see if it's going to work out.
And then, we also have deaf interns
and so, we're seeing how that works
as far as having internship
experience with people
who have disabilities and
internship experience with those
who work in the deaf community.
So, from Gallaudet, we just recently
had an intern named Swanhilda
and her internship
consisted of a few things.
It consisted of researching
and looking into deaf culture,
using library resources
and equipment
to really find the library's
resources that are available.
And then, she developed
a presentation.
At her presentation, there were
about 50 people in attendance.
She's from a seventh
generation deaf family.
So, really, the work that she
produced was very deeply analyzed.
The next slide I'm going to show a
short three-minute clip of a video
that summarizes her time
here at the library.
[ Music ]
>> Swanhilda Lily: [Background
Music] I'm doing my internship
at the office of inclusiveness
and compliance which focuses
on accommodations for disability
access, such as interpreters
for deaf people or
services for blind patrons.
I'm doing two separate internships,
one for my ASL major and the other
for my deaf studies major.
I teach two ASL classes for
the Library of Congress staff
who have deaf work colleagues.
For the deaf studies major, I
research about deaf culture,
deaf history, folk life
and other similar topics.
We have a research shelf here so if
I want to request specific books,
they'll bring these in
for me to do my research.
[ Music ]
>> Travis Painter: Swanhilda
picked an in-depth topic
for her research using the materials
and resources here in the library.
She developed her research and then
did her presentation, which was open
to the public for the
library's employees.
It was well received.
[ Music ]
>> Swanhilda Lily:
Internships are important
because they allow you the
opportunity to learn, make mistakes
and to grow your experience
before you enter the workforce.
[ Music ]
>> Travis Painter: The internship
is a perfect match for the library
because of our focus on education.
Interns observe the work
environment and they learn
about various service units, their
roles and how the library runs
as a cohesive institution.
Even just showing up for work,
they learn about being on time,
about time management
and interacting
and learning from professionals.
Also, they learn about the
importance of communicating
with their supervisors
and other administrators.
[ Music ]
>> Swanhilda Lily: After I graduate,
I'd like to pursue a masters degree
in sign language teaching
at Gallaudet University,
known for having the best
program in the country.
I'll learn about linguistics and how
to analyze the language
in order to teach it.
[ Music ]
My internships here at the Library
of Congress have helped
me understand the dynamics
of working with hearing people.
I've also learned more about the
deaf community in my research.
So, these two internships
have been instrumental
in increasing my overall
understanding, which will enable me
to become a better
advocate and teacher.
[ Music ]
>> Travis Painter: So Gallaudet
actually produced that video.
They came and did all the
filming of Swanhilda and the work
that she had done here
at the library.
And one of her goals
here was to teach ASL.
She had two classes with
about 15 students in each one.
And so, on the lunch break
that the employees have,
they would go to class
and actually learn ASL.
So, the employees here at the
library are really motivated
and interested to pick up
the language and get involved
and learn that communication.
Here at the library, there are
about 20 deaf staff members
and that provides a
lot of opportunity
for interns that are placed here.
So, one of the benefits of
having an intern here is
that they have mentors,
such as a language mentor
and it helps them learn
how to go from--
it helps them understand
bibliographic and monographs
and all these big technical words
that we use here at the library
and to understand the
technical signs that are here.
And a lot of the times, the deaf
staff are actually teaching the
interpreters the signs
that we use, so,
that also benefits
the interns as well.
Another lesson that interns learn
here is how to be a self advocate.
To have a deaf model, someone to
look up to, so that when they go
out into the world, they know how
to figure out how to be successful.
I'm just going to back up a little
here, and here at the library,
there's two different programs
and they can somewhat coincide.
So, the first program
is like an internship.
And that is the work
experience program.
So, I talked about how to be
successful as a professional
and that comes with the
WEP and then the SPP,
which is the Selective
Placement Program.
That works in a somewhat
different way.
For example, if you have submitted
an application with a letter--
a schedule A to prove that
you have a disability,
the library also has a list.
So, it's easier to be placed
in an available position
when there's a list and a resume
that coincide with one another
and we can somewhat fast-track
your hiring here at the library.
So, if the SPP wants
to hire someone,
they're going to look
at the WEP program.
They're going to look at
interns who have experience here.
The manager is already familiar
with their work performance
and they're going to know that
they're capable of doing the job.
So then, the internship becomes
a position and they transfer
into a fulltime employee.
So, these are two--
this is a picture of two
of our current employees
here at the library.
And this is an example of
two people who were first WEP
and then became permanent employees
at the library through the SPP.
Typically, you see that the managers
in a work environment are hearing.
And they have an understanding
somewhat of what deafness means.
But they don't really
know how to apply that.
So, when they have an intern come
in who's deaf, they're just kind
of shocked in understanding that,
oh wow, they actually can do
that or they can do this.
And so, oh, you know, sometimes,
you get questions like, oh,
deaf people can drive
and things like that.
And so, this is a very
up-front way for them to see
that deaf people are
able to communicate.
They can type, they can do
tactile, they can make video calls.
They have all of these
solutions to problems
that hearing people may
perceive as troublesome.
So, the best way to
learn about culture is
to be social within that culture.
Now, before you all leave, I
actually want to introduce you
to the interns, one, the one
that's voicing right now,
and then the other intern that
we have here from Gallaudet.
So, if you both don't
mind, if you could come up.
>> And for those of you
listening to the English,
we'll have a switch in voices here.
>> Travis Painter: And I'll let
the interns introduce themselves.
>> Jessica: Hi, I'm
Jessica [assumed spelling],
a current Gallaudet
student who's interning here
at the Library of Congress.
>> Mekaella: And my
name is Mekaella.
I am the interpreter intern here
from Eastern Kentucky University.
>> Travis Painter: Would you
mind talking about your major,
your graduation plans and how you've
been using your experience here
at the library to achieve the goals
that you have for your futures?
>> Jessica: My major is
international studies.
I have a friend who actually
works at the Library of Congress
who recommended that I come
here for the internship.
And I was very fortunate.
I do know French and English.
So, coming from the African-American
department, I have some experience--
but because I wasn't familiar
with Library of Congress,
I had someone here who
was able to help guide me
through that learning curve.
And I immediately felt comfortable
because of that relationship.
I wasn't expecting that they would
be so accommodating when it came
to interpreters and other
things that I may need in order
to successfully go
about my internship.
It really helped me feel
more comfortable as an intern
and ultimately, it
was very empowering.
I learned a lot and
I'm learning a lot.
For example, if someone asks me to
refer to a particular research item,
I can go through the
Library of Congress,
find whatever it is that's needed.
So, I highly recommend an
internship experience here
at the Library of Congress.
>> Mekaella: I'm a double major
at-- in school, in deaf studies
and interpreting, in the
interpreting training program.
I also have a minor
in political science.
When I started here
at this internship,
I really got involved in a lot.
I've planned three events that
have focused on deaf culture.
The first one has been about
the technological influence
in the deaf world.
So, looking at TTY's or video
phones, cochlear implants
and hearing aids and how those
things have influenced deaf culture
and ASL or deaf language.
I've also looked at
De'VIA, which is deaf art.
And that is art that's made by
deaf people or that is influenced
by deaf culture in some way.
A third event, which will actually
be taking place next Tuesday is
going to be talking about
how to preserve deaf culture.
If you remember in
the past, you know,
that its had his famous
video reminding people
that education was
going to be important
for the success of
the deaf community.
Unfortunately, we have seen a lot
of deaf schools shutting their doors
and deaf studies-- deaf
clubs can seize to exist.
So, we're going to have
an interesting discussion
on which ways we can continue
to preserve the deaf
culture here in America.
My fourth event is also related to
culture, but it's actually related
to my own heritage
as a Samoan American.
So, we'll be talking about
Samoan culture and all four
of these events have been part
of my internship assignments
that have required research
through the library's resources,
but also interacting with folks
who have first-hand experience
in the topics that
we've been studying.
So, I'm very happy to have-- I had
mentorship opportunities with some
of the interns here at the library.
To have a critical eye on my
work and to get into experiences
that I wouldn't otherwise had which
has really improved my confidence
and my ability not just
in my interpreting skills
but in my social skills with the
consumers with whom I worked, so.
Yeah, I guess that was
a lot but that's it.
>> Travis Painter: All right.
Thank you very much and thank you
to everyone here for your attention.
A question from the audience?
>> I actually have
three questions here.
For the first-- Well,
for the first comment,
I really appreciate
Travis making combinations
for deaf-blind interpreter here.
I greatly appreciate that and I
really would like to thank you
from the bottom of my heart.
As an individual who has done
a great deal of volunteer work,
unpaid, I have a great love
for the deaf-blind community.
It can be sort of a
dark work, if you will.
The next comment I like to make
is that I've noticed the luck is
in the Library of Congress,
you know,
when it comes to deaf-blind I just
like to make a quick statement.
I wen to Cleveland where they had a
library for the blind and a friend
of mine named Art [assumed
spelling] was--
>> Was there and was
shocked by their resources.
>> Was there and was floored
by the resources available.
The number of recordings
and tapes, for example.
And now, to come here today,
the idea of having braille
is something mentioned here.
I know that DC has two separate
buildings, one is the Library
of Congress and the other
is Library for the Blind.
So, I'm wondering if there is
someone else who can be connected
on behalf of the Library
of Congress.
I know that deaf-blind individuals
are in the cultural group of deaf,
in general, so I think,
it would be nice
to have an internship opportunity
that would include members
of the community who
might be deaf-blind.
Once I transfer from my former
school to Gallaudet University,
I felt like it was a life-changing
experience to be in a community
where I can communicate on my own.
When I went back to Ohio to
explain the advocacy for individuals
who might be deaf-blind,
it seem like it wasn't received
as well as I would like.
So, that's why I'm putting
that out there to you.
And lastly, I like to mention,
I've been to Jamaica and I've been
to Africa twice and
at the embassy there,
they said that they actually
have a library for those coming
from international places.
And I was also floored by that.
So, something that I'm impressed
with is the fact that America feels
that it is important to have a
library, to educate individuals
and have materials
available for them to read.
And, you know, there is this
woman in mind, a deaf woman,
who knows all things
related to the library.
So, I was wondering if it would
be possible for you to correspond
with other countries because I know
that Gallaudet University
is recognized
as a fairly funded
university in Washington DC,
so I guess my question to you is
that do you have relationships
with other countries in which you
can educate about deaf culture
and also about deaf-blind?
And the reason I say that
is because I've noticed
in those international countries,
often, there is no education on how
to serve community members
that may be deaf-blind.
So, with that, I'd
like to say thank you.
>> Travis Painter: All right.
That's great, yeah, we are
always open to many opportunities
to learn things and to be exposed
to new situations from employees.
You are correct that Taylor
Street is the location of that--
the library, it's called,
Library for the Blind
and Physically Handicapped
and what is it?
NL--
>> NLS.
>> Travis Painter: -- NLS,
yeah, thank you very much
for that, from the audience.
So, that is typically, the place
that blind patrons would go
for resources and there are
no deaf employees there.
We do have a blind intern
here at this location.
He works in the IT department.
And there's also a deaf person who
works in the IT division as well.
So, to see the interactions
that those two people have
had has been interesting.
As far as I know, there have been no
deaf-blind people who have applied
for internships here at
the Library of Congress.
If you have the any
further information or would
like to refer anyone my way, I
would certainly be happy to see
that program improved by the
inclusion of deaf-blind people.
>> Hi, this is Dan again.
I think I might refer you to Art.
Art actually lives in DC and he's
someone who's more knowledgeable
when it comes to the
deaf-blind community.
>> Travis Painter: All right.
Well, please take down my e-mail
address which is listed here
on the slide and be in contact.
I wasn't sure that I was
supposed to have an open question
and answer period but if that's
what the audience would have for--
I'm also available after
the workshop is over.
If you'd like to come up to me
personally and have a conversation
about the opportunities here.
So, I think I will turn it back
to John Cole to close us out.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Well, all I can
say is thank you to the audience
and for everyone who has planned
this and participated in this today.
At the beginning of the day, I told
you it would be a varied informative
but also informal day where
we would cut across some
of the usual specialties
that are presented.
And also have a chance for a
discussion and a sharing of ideas.
And one of the reasons that we
are pleased to record this is
to keep track of the ideas and
of the people in a friendly way
so we can get back to you
to take advantage of some
of the wonderful thoughts and
ideas that have come forth today.
This, as I said in
the past, has been a--
an annual event, really not even
quite annual, of between the center
for the book, which is the outreach
part of the Library of Congress
which itself reaches out to NLS,
the National Library for the Blind
and Physically Handicapped.
And this is a way that we are
determined to continue to reach
out to the deaf community.
And who knows, maybe even
the center, the book can help
in an informal way in
bringing these groups together.
That's what the Library of Congress
does it is an open institution
funded by the American
tax payer supported
by our country our government.
And it's the right
thing that we want to do
and you have helped us do it.
I'm just very pleased today
that the meeting started
with our acting librarian Mr. Mao.
We had him visit even though I
reported to you on the person
who has been nominated to
become the Librarian of Congress
who is the form-- who
is the head currently
of Enoch Pratt Free Library.
She was quite interested in the
fact we were doing this today.
She wasn't able to join us.
She's not official yet but the
prospects, I think, are good.
But most of all, I really like to
thank everyone from Alec, Alice,
Ricardo, Travis our two
wonderful speakers, Myron Uhlberg
and Harry Lang who brought a
perspective to what we're doing,
historic perspective that
helps us for the future.
And I'm a historian just of the
Library of Congress but I believe
that we go forward in the future
with the Library of Congress
with knowledge of our
history and that is saying,
it is certainly is true for deaf
culture and some of the areas
that we care about
deeply as the society.
Unless we have the historical
perspective and the guidance
from the past, we aren't
going to make the progress--
the kind of progress that we
want to have in the future.
So, I would like now to
thank the participants
for not only your questions
but your close involvement
for your different opinions
and your different ideas.
And I can assure you that using
this platform in the future
that we will go ahead and explore
together and make progress together.
And we will be continuing
to do things
through the National Literary
Society of the deaf Alec
and Ricardo, too and Alice
all that are involved in this.
And I look forward to the
next time we can get together.
I'd like to conclude
with a round of applause
for our participants
and our sponsors.
They've done a wonderful job
for bringing as all together.
Thank you so much.
And declare the day finished.
It's been a terrific
day for the Library
of Congress and I hope for you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.